oh everybody
thank you thank you for coming to our
show on friday
thank you thank you live friday baby
yeah
from my basement you know how it's right
here baby
it is friday baby you know how late
shows go
live from new york new york city i guess
that's snl but we go
live from my basement
from half way underground
live from my nuclear fallout shelter
this is
h3 after dark friday baby yeah
it's also not even dark it's not dark
it's the middle of the day
um thank you everybody for joining us
how's everybody's friday going you know
i'm feeling sore from yesterday
i got brutal work i'm sorry too we're
both exercising
yeah and i kind of like being sore
though
like it's an accomplishment sometimes
it's a pain like
something my legs are so sore i can't
get up yeah that i don't like yeah me
too
but i'm sticking to it people i'm
sticking to it
and i'll tell you what friday thank you
friday's my cheat day
and i'm skipping breakfast because i
know i'm gonna get into some trouble
later
i appreciate that i think you're you're
doing it right yeah
thank you i deserve fried chickens [ __ ]
because i know it's my cheat day so hey
let's just be reasonable here i'm not
trying to [ __ ] my whole life up
we're also going on a date tonight
yo show your nails ela came out here
like damn look at this [ __ ] oh
she has never got her nails done i keep
looking at myself and i'm like i don't
recognize this hand pink hair
pink the hands i don't know
what i like i think you look good
yeah i think it looks good it's like i
feel like your whole life you
have this idea of like who you are and
things you would never do
it's like i'm not one of those nail
person yeah i know i know but i was like
it's so stupid like i kind of want to
try everything
that i usually said i wouldn't do well
you're on the hair game and your hair
looks [ __ ] awesome
and the vibe i feel like you just have
good vibes since you started messing
with your hair
i like it you're having more fun you're
confident you're on instagram a vibe
well also it's like i've i've always
felt like i
my hair was so boring and i'm all about
color
but i always thought that wasn't me i
don't know why
and now i'm having so much fun it's like
i'm all about color white why
i haven't got a vibe before right he's
gotta buy it
vibe check pat you look past the vibe
check today
you do too stop it you gotta vibe
i feel like everyone's lying to me when
they tell me i'm looking good no no
i'm still fat we're not nobody's lying
i mean but you're doing it right and it
is happening
so i think that's the best thing ever
because if it was happening when you
were doing
like starvation challenge starvation
challenges keto
i then i was worried because it's like
okay but what happens when you
go back to normal yeah but
daddy i don't know i'm scared i'm scared
because i have this raging food
addiction and i'm going to lose the
weight
but like i'm still going to have the
addiction do you understand what i'm
saying
but even just acknowledging it i think
is already probably oh i've been
acknowledging it for years
um
[Music]
um speaking of oh well so actually you
guys
by popular demand you guys know how i
told this story of my trainer saying
money baby as i was collapsed on the
floor
well yesterday i actually got him to say
it for for tick tock so
by popular demand here is my trainer
saying money to me
okay guys this is what a fat idiot
who smokes looks like after an hour of
exercise
it's money ethan thank you dude
that's money you guys hear that okay
guys
this is what a [ __ ] family got what
you wanted
money is he still totally out of the uh
loop on the
the fact that well on the show
i don't know if he's not letting on all
the way because
the first day he was saying money about
everything and then after i made it he
pretty much stopped saying money
yeah so i think he must have seen it and
he's playing a little koi with me
because i was like yo i told this
because i was like i told this story on
tick
uh on the show about how um you were you
were just saying money and i was like
just a corpse on the floor and i thought
it was funny
so i told him you know because he
doesn't say money anymore
yeah now we got the sound bite thank you
for that soundbite
you're welcome zach just for you can i i
want to show you something
ela yeah and i do this with peace and
love of course
yeah oh this isn't what i wanted to show
you but it's on my computer screen this
is something that
showed up on my homepage whoa
it's just some homie oh he's got some
hardcore hip-hop
i mean this is just he looks he's got a
face like one of those dogs
there's a dog that has that exact same
face
i feel like he's english do you guys
know what i mean
that's racist i kind of i think i know
what you
mean do you know what i mean he must be
english anyway he just has one video
and it got four points he just said made
one video he has 4.4 million views
wow really yeah because everyone's like
whoa whoa
and i had the same reaction was on my
homepage
you know that's crazy and amazing
thanos someone says he looks like thanos
hmm he's more like mr magu man
it's reminding me of an alien but i i
can't put my finger on
um what it is exactly my thumb after a
very long bath
oh come on you guys he's just trying to
put himself out there on tick tock
having a vibe
it's a great tick tock yeah everyone's
waiting for number two he already got 50
000 followers he's probably like what
anyway that's not what i wanted to show
you what i did want to show you is okay
you know zac efron is right heartthrob
do you fight think he's handsome here
i'll show you
zac efron and the heartthrob yeah
i mean yeah he's handsome i'm not gonna
argue that he's not handsome
you [ __ ] zac efron i didn't say that
okay you think he's a good lover i can't
tell is that girlfriend a good lover you
think about him
you think he's a tender lover or no i
don't know thank you i gotta call
him thank you dan
okay well the point is is that he got
some kind of plastic and i say this was
peace and love again because you know
i'm not i know people get plastic
surgery
it's a personal thing and it's a choice
and i you know whatever you want to do
to make yourself feel good god bless
but he got plastic surgery
and i just don't know man i just
wait so what did he do i don't know i
don't know what he did but he got
he did something right yeah it looks
like his jaw's swollen
but he looks like one of those plastic
surgery memes kind of oh yeah
the lips he did like someone else now
he's reminding me
i don't know who though i can't put the
name chin jaw
and d lips what is d i'm sorry and lips
yeah he did something to his lips and
jaw but i just i was like i
look so different you know i saw him
recently in a netflix document he was
looking at his handsome usual self
but man
i don't know you looked more like zach
travolta now
zach travolta i guess my point is
is that i mean our wishes that's real
are we sure this is real yeah but dan
send it to me
uh ian but um it was all over it was all
over twitter
oh this is all over twitter so people
are having kind of a similar reaction
yeah it's trending on twitter poor guy i
feel bad for him actually because
first of all you don't do this unless
you're like deeply insecure about your
looks
right so like he obviously had some kind
of issue with his physical appearance i
don't know what because he's like
perfect face
but now he's gonna he was always known
as like the perfect face guy
good looking guy you know yeah
so he was obviously really insecure and
now everyone's clowning him on twitter
let me pull up those tweets now i'm
really curious to see what people are
saying right me too
um let's see twitter search zac efron
but this just goes to show you man
handsome beautiful people
this guy uh oh no he looks like shrek
no well not like ogre handsome shrek
handsome shrek no he does look like a
cgi character
he looks like cancer together i'd kill
her to look like a handsome shrek
so this is him before the i mean that's
great
yeah i don't see any issues of course
only he sees it that's the problem
that's why i guess i should relate
because i'm like that i see
a million issues in my cell phone zac
efron
that's not him but you get the point
that's what he's going towards
but the mean yeah oh yeah ruthless bro
zac efron why
they're not happy but the po i guess the
point is that i'm trying to make is that
you know
just be happy with what you got people
because if zac efron's insecure to the
point of
mingling his face like this then you
just gotta work it
don't worry and guys i just i really
want people to understand that plastic
surgery never helps
it never helps it no it only makes you
look
weird in your opinion
let's not say it as a fact and you don't
in your opinion when it works well you
don't notice it
is the thing okay i guess i guess there
are some minor things
people do for sure i don't know once you
start doing like facelifts and
and and and filler it's like whoa yeah
yeah i just i like people that age
gracefully
i think it always looks better you don't
think that you end up gracefully well
yeah sure
he clearly didn't think he was aging
gracefully
okay ethan okay
oh you know rob blow that i think that's
what i was trying to think oh yeah
he does look kind of like him now
totally see that
yeah and rob lowe you [ __ ] rob lowe
right
a handsome dude i mean i don't like
saying if i would [ __ ] someone
okay you're attracted i'm married yeah
okay you're married to me
what are all these images can someone
find me roblox
why don't we try to be more family
friendly like we just started the show
why even say the f word
family friendly who are we making before
eight-year-olds
watch
[Laughter]
wait this doesn't look that bad there's
got to be better photos than this
on the right side ones before ones after
uh this photo's weird
well what is this one on the right this
comparison
hey b this is the worst thing i've ever
seen
what am i supposed to take away from
this
telling him before you were a weirdo
you don't have a better one and now he's
a stone guy from the 70s um
anyway today
there's a big ass bombshell article
about jake paul
and team 10. i just want to say not
bombshell i read it it isn't interesting
though
interesting read you know we put
bombshell on the top oh man
it well well it kind of it's a i felt
like it was kind of a bombshell really
like
it's from the perspective of this 13
year old boy who
greg paul by the way his dad jake
dad got involved to convince the parents
he was gonna be okay greg paul by the
way is outside in a van [ __ ] the
friends
and this 13 year old was like sleeping
on the floor
i didn't have food was sharing rooms
with olivia
his girlfriend she was like 19 at the
time
i did wish that they would have touched
on that but they didn't in the article
what do you mean
about the dad pizza oh well they
mentioned allegations about him oh yeah
right yeah because all that i mean
that is even though we saw the video you
never actually see anybody's face in
that video it's all
i don't think it's completely well you
don't know who the girl is it's
definitely great
even just what we've seen of him
participating in that kissing video
oh that's a good point that that should
that could have been included
yeah i agree great that he's involved
in any capacity with these guys yeah oh
he was 14. and apparently he says when
he was 14
he had sex with like a 24 year old and
he's like kind of traumatized about it
now
jesus are we gonna talk about it now
yeah i'm gonna get it i'm gonna get into
it but the point is
oh i'm sorry it was alyssa violet who he
was sharing a room with like weird she's
like 10 years older
a girl too anyway um
i'm going to talk about that and then
the author
taylor lorenz right that's correct he's
calling in to discuss
so that's fun exciting from the new york
times people
we're moving up in the world moving on
up so
she's gonna be calling a little bit
later i actually have a lot of
i'm really curious about uh a lot of the
stuff in this
impressive stuff to be talking to in new
york times
dude look at us look at us we are not
effing around
we are i'm saying f now because i'm
trying to be friendly thank you and
respect to the new york times
so we got that scoop um
do you guys find this weird i actually
i'm going to talk about all this stuff
next up but there's one more thing that
came across my desk
this morning and i i understand he's
doing a good thing
right like it's cool prisoners are
people and
you know they often are are overlooked
as others in our society and the way
they're treated
but jake paul here i'm just to play
so he's singing to like 20 that is not
jake paul
my brain does not work today justin
bieber clearly justin bieber
i was confused what you were talking
about you ethan you have to make your
words make sense for the show to work
this is a verbal show stop me
justin bieber singing i'm so lonely to
like 20 prisoners
thoughts what's your problem
it's just like why so he's like damn you
trying to get these guys to kill
themselves or what listen to this
wow i'm so lonely
i'm so lonely no
he's like all right see you guys maybe
they
identify with it or something i don't
know you're just hating yeah i could be
just hating that's why i wanted to ask
you guys i doubt the care
listen i'm totally open to me being a
[ __ ] hater
i mean that's why i'm bringing it up for
discussion i think it's a nice thing
i mean hey i would like it i think it's
depressing
live show like that yeah maybe thinks
it's depressing he says
i mean anything in prison is depressing
yeah they're probably vibing though it's
probably emotional experience for them
yeah i'm so lonely maybe different song
though
it's a beautiful song maybe baby baby
baby baby baby
or what was the really cringe one yummy
you're not listening i'm sorry what
what'd you say friday joke yeah i missed
it i'm sorry my brain is out
i'm gonna move no you tell me because
the joke was not good
no tell me now i said they should sing
about
the peaches one that's trending with the
i get my weight from california
i heard that okay it wasn't is it a joke
though i mean it's just a suggestion for
a song
am i missing the joke i mean and they're
imprisoned oh
yeah but wheat is legal now come on if
he was like i smoked meth
i went to jail for smoking meth okay but
it doesn't have a song like that
yeah the one about criminality okay i
get it
i get my meth from california that's it
i get my meth from bakersfield yeah
that's [ __ ]
okay johnny cash famously went to a
prison and sang songs about
committing crimes and stuff yeah i
thought that was cool
uh listen okay let's let's move on shall
we start over
let's restart hey everybody welcome
today podcast coming at you
today we don't oh perfect timing to
mention my beautiful capable wife
who has just released teddyfresh.com
head on over to teddyfresh.com to repeat
our new release
stuff is moving fast this quilted hoodie
already sold out that was [ __ ]
some next level [ __ ] man we got the
flames we got the we got some t-shirt
the earth day shirts sold out
this one's still here we love this shirt
coming at you
hey coming at you live we got all these
shirts all right go to take foreign
okay so we talked about the jake paul
fight in our previous episode but we
didn't have time to get to a lot of the
great
stuff from it that i wanted to talk
about like pete savinson moments
and then jake paul talking about the
fight afterwards on impulsive with his
dad greg who's the most embarrassing
person alive
if you you know how i have like some
issues with my dad i love my dad he
watches the show so peace and loved him
but if greg paul was my dad i would
[ __ ]
move to like rural i would like change
my identity i would change my last year
peace out so your dad is not that bad
oh my god my dad is i thank god my dad
is my dad
thanks to the paul brothers we have new
appreciations
gp coming at you it could always be
worse you know my one thing my dad used
to say which is true
he says if you could put if you could
put all your problems in a hat
and take out new problems you would want
your own back at the end of the day
and i've always thought all my life
reflected on that and been like you know
what that's probably true
did he make that up no he heard it from
someone
it's a nice one he used to also say i
like it
he used to also say um when someone asks
how are you doing
you go better uh you would say
better than better than most not
as good as some knowledge
thank you ty all right let's just i
think you can just say i'm fine thank
you
i'm fine yeah that's what fine means not
great i'm not bad
right why you need so many words
so pete davidson before the show i was
watching all this crap
he goes back in the locker room and asks
jake about his essay allegations and
they
they cut out the whole audio um
does it has anyone actually heard it
like
no and to be honest i i'm not 100
convinced that's what
it is what yeah well let's watch because
then how do you just cut out the audio
i assume that this was pre-recorded
because i thought it was no it was live
it was live and you can tell afterwards
this was like so awkward
well here watch it watch you tell me
what you think
ready to explode keep cranking
but i'm good bro yeah you're awesome you
remind me of like
when charlie sheen when he went on his
winning tirade
everybody was just like go off dude go
on
i didn't get that he's very calm but
okay
what i was gonna ask you about i was
like so how are you feeling like
so here they cut cut a lot
bro you can't joke around about that no
you can't joke around about that
mm-hmm but i i'm not no i'm like are you
are you good
good i'm good bro i'm feeling good
what's popping with that nothing
right yeah okay cool so that's it this
whole interview
oh wow comfortable all right so i was
watching this thing and i was like
whoa this is crazy so
i just wonder if anyone did get to here
because like
how does it work technically you have a
kill switch something yeah you could do
a live you can have a kill switch where
you cut the audio
so they it's like it's being broadcast
on the delay exactly
they have the same thing on live radio
like someone that was in charge of broad
broadcast immediately made the decision
to cut it yes so curious yeah
like what happened because they probably
because triller which jake's is an
investor in and on the
this was like a huge story that everyone
was talking about so i'm sure they were
like okay
if anyone mentions this you kill you
kill the audio
okay yeah they do the same thing on live
radio
like they have a kill switch where they
can cut the audio
you hit a button and it retroactively
dumps like the last
goes right yes exactly we'll do it live
we could do it but apparently we need
some expensive equipment right
um i haven't looked into it in a few
because we you asked me about it when i
first started working for you
um but broadcast uh gear has gotten a
lot cheaper in the last few years
because of
all the streamers and everything so
there may actually be a cheaper way to
do it now the professional way to do it
yeah that equipment is like
50 grand yeah i remember i was like i
was like yo if i say something like
really dumb can we just kill switch it
and dan's like it costs 50 grand i was
like
[ __ ] it i'd rather get cancelled
it's possible it's possible there's
cheaper ways to do it now i i haven't
looked into it in a while check it out
let's enjoy this interview though
because it's really i was a boxer the
last
he goes the last thing i'd want is a
bunch of people coming here to talk to
you before i fought
it's like okay dude
yeah if i was a boxer i feel like the
last thing i want is [ __ ]
coming in here asking me questions
yeah oh you guys are good we were going
to keep it really light like mostly like
what's your favorite color
um yeah i can tell what it is
they proceed to have an actual
conversation about what's your favorite
color
yeah right we'll say it on on three
on three guys favorite colors yellow no
no no money no no blue man
blue i also have questions about your
robot
um yeah this is it's just it's just it's
a train wreck
it's really god it's really hard
it's really hard man and so
that was that there's also images that
were a meme of jake
stretching before the show and maybe
this is why he's so calm
but he's get he gets down with some wild
stretches i don't even know what i'm
looking at frankly speaking
they cut away to this at one point yeah
and he was just that's his head right
there yeah yeah
legs right let's get after it
money baby whoa that's
me on the floor after exercising for 10
minutes
thank you
um okay so so
now you go to the after the fight jake
paul knocks out
the out of shape boxer we talked about
that last episode
but this is when jake paul now he's
angry at pete
because pete went to the other to ben's
locker and was like yo i was just
kissing up to jake
but i [ __ ] hate that guy and
everybody hates him
and so jake gets like seriously offended
i was confused on why
his pit there and who hired him because
it's like
well jake says he's the one that hired
him jake said it was his thing to have
him on there
it was i mean so jake got owned yeah for
sure he got played hard
he got played yeah well what did he
think like what what
some some like actual respectable
comedians gonna come here and just kiss
his feet like i'm sorry bro
yeah no known savage
known savage pete davidson yeah
ian do you have a problem with pete
davidson because i see you calling him a
savage ironically
quite a bit it's a meme that ian and i
have been
passing back and forth for years youtube
just youtube just
constantly for a few months was
recommending me pete davidson savage
compilations
[Music]
so i'm kind of still learning but i felt
like it was
pretty funny yeah he was keeping it real
considering the situation like it's not
it's not easy to stay real like that
and um i don't know it was pretty funny
i agree
it was good that have someone to
cast the like everybody's thinking this
is what
exactly i feel like it's what almost 80
percent of the people
were thinking and he actually said it
yeah i mean
i don't know maybe you can pull a
compilation of savage moments from that
night for us to watch
but he was like someone's for sure made
it
is it here oh
some people yeah here it is you're right
here let's watch this before we watch
jake paul
react to it savage moments guys yeah
seems really important uh you could tell
how professional this event
is by uh them having me here uh we
are backstage at jake paul's dressing
room or locker room if you want to call
it that
and uh you know today's a really wild
day for boxing because it just shows you
know how low
is truly sunk uh
i mean maybe pewdiepie will cure cancer
and charlie dimiglio will become a
surgeon
uh who knows tonight we have a bout
between
ben askren who i don't know who that is
still and i've been uh reading up on him
all week and jake paul
and uh you know they both suck but you
know
at least somebody's gonna get hurt now
back to you guys in the booth
uh some real announcers over there hello
sir
i don't know why he's [ __ ] on ben
though i don't think ben did anything
wrong oh he said maybe
he he said he lost a bunch of money on
him once so he's got like a chip
on his shoulder i don't know how are you
doing good what's your beef pig i
want to ask you the same thing i don't
have a beef with you you just said he
sucks
no you tweeted and you said you you
started the
the beef you said uh oh great i can't
wait to be part of a
show that has me commentating on it yeah
so i immediately was like what the [ __ ]
because
nobody wants you to lose this you know
you want me to win
yeah nobody wants to see jake paul win i
have to be not you got to understand i'm
hosting i have to be nice in there he
has eight dudes standing around him
with literally nothing with nothing to
lose
and it's just you in here so it's
actually a lot more safe not even my
underwear too
so it's gonna make you feel right at
home oh that's great i don't think they
study in acting school like just pretend
you're in your underwear
yeah something like that yeah believe me
nobody wants uh
anything other than for you to you know
knock this guy on his ass well
yeah i appreciate that much i do that
yeah that would make me really happy how
are you feeling man how do you feel that
didn't work out
yeah bro that was the worst showing of
all time oh man youth culture
that's true um he kind of has this whole
like
following so he thinks he can kind of do
whatever it is here this is the thing
and like
didn't he like get busted by the feds
with like aks and like a bunch of
machine gun
like why isn't yeah exactly do you think
jake paul is uh
asking for it my kids are not watching
no i can't tell you that i'm gonna have
to kick his ass on behalf of your kids
yes
yeah absolutely yeah do you think this
is something that i wrote i i came very
prepared okay
do you think jake paul is uh asking for
it
sorry sorry i wrote that i've never
heard that oh
so savage that was a savage i was really
psyched to ask you that and uh i just
said it out loud and i'm very
embarrassed
um no man i have zero beef with you at
all i'm we're
we're on your side nice yeah i
appreciate it we all
why don't you like jake just because
he's a douche well i mean
do you have an hour i mean
i mean he's not a good person uh he's
clearly
uh you know is not a good influence on
any of the youth culture
that's true um he kind of has this whole
like
following so he thinks he can kind of do
whatever he wants
and like didn't he like get busted by
the feds with like aks
and also did he essay someone yes anyway
that's that okay so jake gets really
pissed about this
i want to see jake paul versus pete
davidson oh
hey mike can you just shut the [ __ ] up
for a minute what is mike doing there i
thought
good question no not friends anymore
no i don't think they're not no they're
still doing their thing apparently he's
flying out to puerto rico every week i
don't know dude the whole thing is weird
didn't he just talk [ __ ] about logan he
did yeah
yeah he did wait wait
go ahead maybe he did on um a podcast
but
they made up but yeah they were fighting
on twitter going back and forth but they
always seem to fight and make up yeah
mike's life is falling apart i'm here
for it he got dumped
and there's like all this drama it's
pretty epic we'd love to see it
zach right do we hate mike here on this
show i'm sorry what was that
he [ __ ] those gym shorts we have it on
good authority that he shits his gym
shards
shits his gym shorts no i don't wish
anything bad on mike but i do think he's
a douche
yo hey can i fight that little piece of
[ __ ] oh my god
listen who put him on the set how is he
here he beats gp but he said
hold on he's like six three six four
uh uh i'm [ __ ] let's go you [ __ ] him
i know go on fight let's go
after i beat his ass i'm a [ __ ]
savage god so here is their white
trash their dad is the whitest trash
person alive
sitting here in his oakley in his
[ __ ] like uh
you know colorful lenses backwards hat
sitting here how he's gonna
unironically beat up pete davidson his
and his shirt says
problem child spelled wrong that's your
childhood i'm a [ __ ] savage you got
that problem yeah the problem
is that's the result of your parenting
dude
yeah oh the oakley's it's just too
perfect
yeah he's just the ultimate dude why did
they let him on set i just
i don't get it gp's up
hey hackers you guys are really good you
know hacking is just
a form of adult bullying you got to pull
that zach
adult rather speak up and be wrong and
be muffled
and be wrong talking about yeah he got
i do it hey man can we get security man
it's only coming at you oh
[ __ ] dale yeah pete davidson uh
i think he took the mvp that's at the
mvp i'm gonna be honest with with you it
was
oh i mean there was a well jake took the
okay look when you got the mvp
there was a lot of people who were just
not fans of the event yeah
and and he spoke directly to those
people
those people who were who were like i
don't want to see so why
were they watching if they weren't fans
of the event jake
are you really so [ __ ] dumb like can
you just not embrace your infamy like
you're the problem child
you know what i mean just embrace it you
should have someone like pete david
hosting your events every time
it makes it watchable bearable you know
people don't watch because they don't
like you that's the whole reason people
even [ __ ] tune in at all
wait hold on hold on that's your whole
stick
people want to see take their money
by the way it was my idea to like have
him as the host of the event
he talked to me he wants to do all of
the wrestling [ __ ] that guy
he won't do [ __ ] he won't wait he he
won't he won't ever be a part of one of
those ever again
he [ __ ] this [ __ ] up bro bro i was i
so he'll go to work for dana white
so i was confused um and i hate and i
hate this is like the problem with like
drama and [ __ ] because it just brings
everyone more clout
it brings him more clout well he got
more clown bro he got clown exactly but
david he's famous you these guys can't
get their [ __ ] heads straight
like they're he doesn't need clout clown
he's pete davidson
ringing mark cloud he doesn't need clout
he's famous
there's a reason we wanted him to host
so stupid he's just on that clock train
yeah like you want
your 12 year old fans anyway
he's such a [ __ ] so i might invent the
clout pill just
[ __ ] that guy do you think he thought he
was doing i don't give a [ __ ] what he
thought his job did you get him saying
like maybe he was doing the roast oh he
said he
no the [ __ ] he said is like [ __ ] you
can't take back okay i didn't hear what
he said
i was confused how that was happening on
your broadcast that's
that's that was the only thing it was
like i'm gonna be honest with you it's
funny
but the context of it didn't make any
sense to me i didn't know because jake
ball hired him and he
owned that was happening yeah and i and
when i spoke to him um
backstage he really did seem like
enthralled by the whole thing he was um
shocked that i guess you're a boxer just
like
care he couldn't wrap his head around at
all and that's what he was kind of like
yeah poking fun
you know um yeah pete davidson was
engaged to ariana grande i don't think
he needs clout from jake paul
uh man the whole family is just so
embarrassing
i need that clout
um here's more jake paul cringe from
that
from that episode the whole time
i don't i don't care like say what you
want like everyone said it
everyone said it but like i'm what a lot
of people don't understand about me and
i think i proved it last night is like
i'm a real [ __ ] like i'm a real
[ __ ]
like i do all this social media [ __ ] i'm
on disney channel being a fool i'm
cringe
[ __ ] blah blah blah yeah jake paul
the eight letter the brain don't work
around the world i think but nothing
you guys think i'm dumb get a load of
this guy talking
sometimes he's doing a dj impression
right
he's definitely putting on a weird i
come from the mud
but it's not good it just sounds dumb
hate on maybe all the chains are
cutting off the circulation funny funny
i can think of another
one when i [ __ ] see you i'm a real
[ __ ] and i'm gonna [ __ ] you up
all right and by the way all these mma
fighters
ufc fight a real fighter dude [ __ ] about
y'all suck my dick
i'm a real mother dude how about you
fight a real box i'm a real [ __ ]
and i'm talking my [ __ ]
i'm talking my [ __ ] on this
[ __ ] impulsive podcast
that's good what's up [ __ ] hello
you got a big [ __ ] heart though and a
head your head is massive
your head is huge big head yeah yeah but
like literally i'm taking
like the size of it all these
[ __ ] do this social media
hoopla [ __ ] i could talk about you on
camera
twitter finger ass [ __ ] bro i
don't play that
i don't play that we'll see um we'll see
you
we'll take paul he wants to tougher
online until we spook them in person
twitter finger [ __ ]
greg this is fantastic i love this
version of jake
yo cause you're right i mean listen this
is what people watch
people watch this trisha watches this i
can't forget trisha
she brings up a pulse of every [ __ ]
time i say this show this is what you're
talking about
no oh man she's gotta
find something else but greg greg paul
really
explains this family because they
obviously have this horrible father
figure
that is just completely corrupted and
rotted away the foundation of these
young men
i'm a [ __ ] savage you gotta do it
that's their dad man i mean damn that is
just bad
that's just i feel bad for that yeah
yeah anyway that's good there's just a
lot of good
stuff people there's a lot of goofs on
jake
just because he's like i'm a real
[ __ ] he started crying after he
knocked out ben
so there was all these really great
memes like jake paul after beating a
walmart cashier in his next fight
[Laughter]
jake paul after fighting everyone that
isn't an actual boxer
that's the same meme the mma community
after watching ash can get one punch by
jake paul yeah
jake paul's next opponent that's
beetlejuice from the howard stern show
he's like three five or something he's
really short oh man
jake paul after baiting a 73 year old
arthritic retired accountant in his next
fight
[Laughter]
this dude is high on jake paul's list of
opponents that's the rap
who stopped the fight
you're tripping the point one percent of
germs that clorox misses
kind of interesting observation
yeah how jake paul feels right now
yeah so that's that was kind of my
opinion too you know i'm not even gonna
lie if he actually hires a real boxer in
his prime
i will watch that but any other stick
i'm out
i'm out i'm i'm overseeing jake beat up
like used car
salesmen who haven't fought in 15 years
they built like me when paul when ben
weighed in i was like
that that's me that's my body
i couldn't believe what i was saying
yeah okay so now we're speaking of jake
paul let's talk about the new york times
article
yeah uh taylor is in the lobby by the
way i don't know if you want to
go first i hope she's got a minute yeah
i want to go over the article first
i have here okay i'm going to read like
my favorite highlights here from it
um so
aaron so this is mostly from the
perspective of this um
who's a man now aaron mitchell oh no aj
so it's
this kid aj who was there when he was
14. so it's mostly from his perspective
aaron mitchell's his dad said he was not
very impressed with jake
so i guess a little backstory yeah
this uh 14 year old boy was trying to
make it
as a musician he had like 80 000
followers at the time on instagram and i
guess jake saw something in him and so
he like aggressively pursued him to join
team 10. also i what i like is that the
article
just to even give a little more
background they take
a look back at team 10 and they say like
how
that was kind of like maybe not the
first um
influencer kind of house thing but it
was definitely the most popular one that
kind of
right off that trend and um
so it was interesting to see them take a
look back at it because i do remember it
being so
weird and it's like you know
things must have gone wrong oh yeah with
that house
well look at it now it's like it's like
everybody left bitterly
they all left bitterly hating jake yeah
so it was interesting to now being a
little
like few years after it see a serious
article
about it well i never even heard of this
kid right
but it sounds like insanely uh
well i'll read it they touch on
everything i want to say
um so it starts here i i grabbed my
favorite excerpts because the article is
kind of long
so aaron mitchell aj's father said he
was not impressed with jake paul at
first and he didn't want his son who was
14 at the time
involved in team 10. however after
extensive conversations with mr paul's
parents
greg paul and pam stepnick
you like that mr paul's assistant erica
costell
who's in her mid-20s and niels visser
another member of
of team 10 he and his wife allison
decided to allow aj to join the group
you gotta appreciate that jake paul's
dad who's there eating out little girls
chill that's not jesus hey i saw it
no you didn't no you didn't what didn't
i see
you didn't see anybody you didn't see
anybody's face
in that video which is kind of gross
just don't say that
okay hit the kill switch dan can we not
have the kill switch i'm a [ __ ]
savage
i haven't managed to get that set up
since you guys remember
when we discussed it we grabbed the
sound bite and you guys made me stop
using because it was yeah it was too
gross
everybody was like you have to stop or
i'm going to stop watching the show
listen
i think we all agree in our opinion it
was
probably greg almost certainly greg but
we can't say bro
you could see his face in the video why
is everyone tiptoeing around this no you
couldn't you could see his narrative
coming at you not for sure
i it was for sure him no you can't say
that
it was what is everybody's
that it's not for sure and he made a
video begging the hackers to get in
contact with him yeah but
it's gp's up you can't come here and say
it was for sure him you just can't
i think the problem is you don't know
who the girl was it was she was young
though probably over 18 though
but anyway hopefully i don't know oh
allegedly it was him i saw his [ __ ]
face
in the video in your opinion well anyway
you got to love the irony of
jake's dad being like no it's totally
safe it's good man it's good here he's
going to be in good hands
and he's outside enough camper [ __ ]
the fan girls
it's crazy now gp coming at you so okay
this
blows my mind that guy's such a piece of
[ __ ]
according to several members how uh
several former house members
mr paul could take 10 to 20 percent
of the team 10's youtube ad revenue for
up to five years even if they left the
group
that part is really sketch yeah
on may 24th mr mitchell arrived at the
team 10 house
with a single suitcase for several weeks
he didn't have a bedroom so he slept on
a leather couch in the living room
mr mitchell was given a room to share
with alyssa violet who was 19 at the
time and publicly dating
mr paul do you find that so odd that
they yeah
a 14 year old boy with a 19 year old
girl
super weird in his down time mr mitchell
would write songs in a notebook and play
them on his keyboard
one day he came home to discover his
keyboard broken mr paul told him it had
been thrown in the pool for a video
followers
um followers were the primary currency
of team 10 house
if you got tagged to one of jake's
youtube videos you could get 50 000
followers mr mitchell said
dan says i swear i can remember seeing
his i just fact checked it did you look
at the
screenshot yeah well i i looked at
a screenshot to remind myself oh yeah
it's the whole thing is first person
from his perspective so you don't see
his face and then i also found an
article in newsweek where it says the
photos were blurred
and the three sex tape clips don't show
any faces okay
i i i retract i this is i ethan klein on
behalf of myself in the history podcast
over here i retract my statement i
apologize sincerely to the paul family
and to greg
that said it's almost certainly him in
my opinion you could say in your opinion
i
i i i apologize for my defamator or well
i don't know if i want to admit it's def
[ __ ] you it's you greg
gp coming at you
gp creep sue me we can do discovery
that's what i always say because you
know when you have to sue someone you
have this
this thing of discovery where you get to
swap and you get to look at all the
source items you're like okay let me see
all you got
you're not gonna sue me because it's
true gp
jp he's like you taking away work
possibilities for me
in my van outside of jake paul's house i
sincerely apologize to greg paul for my
comments i retract it you cannot see his
face with peace and love
followers were the primary currency of
team 10 house if you get tagged in one
of jake
youtube videos you can get 50 000
followers mr uh mr mitchell said
jake would use that to manipulate
everyone if you didn't do what jake
wanted he'd tell everyone in the house
not to tag you
jake had a monopoly and he decided who
got famous not so gross
but there was money coming in too and
members of the group had questions about
where it was going
when team 10 formed mr paul set up and
controlled business email accounts
for each member to solicit opportunities
mr mitchell
said he was not aware of the
opportunities that he was being pitched
for
or what was coming in in the 14 months
he spent as part of the group he said he
was paid directly for two brand deals
but he never received
payment for them from team 10.
mr mitchell relied on small amounts of
money he received from its parents
to cover expenses like meals out with
the group mr paul had convinced mr
mitchell's parents that their son would
be taken care of
but no meal or structure were provided
for him other
or the other teenage residents most of
them had never been expected to shop or
cook for themselves and didn't have the
means to do so
people see these mansions and they see
people living like royalty but no one
knew i was sleeping on the floor and i
didn't have food he said
meanwhile cut cut again to greg paul
being like no no no no you're in good
hands everything's gonna be fine
i'm an adult i'm equally you know it's
like yo folks what's going on it's gp
coming at you
vina double a professor of law at the
university of california
said we have all these laws in place
that have been around for a century to
protect child performers
but they have not been extended to
safeguard the health welfare and safety
of children
influencers because these young creators
make money through a variety of revenue
streams
and are not employed by a single entity
they can be vulnerable to exploitation
if there's not some kind of entity
taking responsibility as an employer
then we're going to see the kind of
exploitative and unsafe practices we
have been seeing she said
you like that that's the problem
yeah yeah who invites a 14 year old into
their home and doesn't [ __ ] like
makes them sleep on the floor and
doesn't give them it's like i'd feed
them
throws their keyboard in the pool makes
them sleep on the floor also they just
get talent for free because basically
they
he probably used them for all his videos
you know he never paid him yeah
um yeah so embarrassing and he makes
them think like they should be thankful
for being in a video because they get
tagged and they get clout
exactly it's wild it's just wild
wild wild wild man um the allure of
living independently and building a
following had worn off
at first i was like there's no parents
here and we get to be free and do what
we want
i felt like free in a way but having
jake be the adult was weird because we
all listened to jake he was the boss
during parties marijuana and alcohol
were available in the team 10 house
mr mitchell 14 years old said he wants
to drink so much he blocked out
nice the group often attended parties
where guests in their 20s and 30s would
mingle with teenagers
mr mitchell said he began a sexual
relationship with a woman nearly a
decade older than him
whom he had met at an influencer party
he understands now that the racial
relationship could not have been
consensual because of his age i was a
baby he said i had a baby face
i feel like that's just so weird now
it wasn't until recently i seen pictures
of myself at 13 14 i look like a baby
yeah the fact that this is just this is
all so wild it wasn't until recently
that mr mitchell told his parents the
full extent of what took place in the
house
mrs mitchell said she was horrified and
angry
i'll tell you right now if i had known
anything about any relationship with a
girl 10 years older than him i would
have had the law involved
yeah i have to say the parents are kind
of dumbasses though
too i didn't want to be rude
but um i mean come on my parents
wouldn't [ __ ] let you go
yeah or any influencer house for that
matter i mean
[ __ ] he's 14.
well his parents they get sucked into
the allure of
the fame and everything it's a classic
it's not a joke it's not a news story
the show biz parents
hey worst things you've given to the
custody of an actual like predator
yeah i've heard of that happening that
definitely happens but i would say
on the whole child actors in hollywood
nowadays
are protected much more than what is
being described you're saying
that's kind of the thing about this
article that's interesting because
this has no rules or they're they're not
following anything like
there's no they're not providing
anything for this case and they're
destroying his property
they're making money off of them it's
crazy sounds like the stories from
the 30s and 40s of you know what uh
what child actors went through back then
several months after mr mitchell's
departure the rest of team 10 was forced
to move
neighbors said mr paul creating living
hell for them and turned their sleeping
neighborhood into a war zone
we're familiar with that story the
following year evan and emilio martinez
two youtubers from spain who had lived
in the team 10
house spoke about their decision to
leave i actually want to open this
because it's so funny but they say
they said in the video i remember this
happening they said mr paul bullied them
terrorized them with pranks and made
racist comments mocking their background
and language skills
they speak english as a second language
i remember when this came out
pretty um i i i feel for them but at the
same time
okay jake they're wearing shirts to say
savage so
[ __ ] you oh man
hi guys we're back so i know we haven't
been posting a lot of videos we're here
to
tell you exactly something something
first we should explain
why no i know i just i just just get a
little taste
a little taste of the twins i want to
get a taste
i want we should make uh do you think
this is a good graphic for teddy fresh
i these guys don't strike me as savages
just saying
peace and love let's not make fun of i
don't think they're savages i mean it's
they're sweet boys take that savage
shirt off
okay now we move on to the uh essay
allegations against jake paul
alyssa violet the girlfriend who was
sharing a room
with um the kid
she said in a 2018 interview with a
youtuber shane
dawson we know him he is not a physical
abuser but mentally and emotionally 100
every day 2 000 times a day she says in
a video i can't remember a conversation
where it was me walking away feeling
good about myself
if we filmed a video he had to push me
into a bush normally you nudge someone
or pretend to push them he would
actually shove me she says
as she shows scars on the camera that
doesn't sound like physical abuse
he would just do it way too hard
so then there's this girl who recently
came out justine
justine paradise 24 year old tick tock
influencer accused paul
of essay you guys heard that when we
discussed it
um it's a she said of it in a situation
like that there's nothing i could do
i was physically restricted and felt
emotionally
restricted afterwards to even say
anything about it three friends whom she
told directly
after about the event corroborated her
account
so the new york times went out of their
way to corroborate this
you know miss paradise says she plans to
file charges
um another one rayleigh lowly 21 a model
actress who began working with mr paul
when she was 17
said he often called her jail bait and
commented on her appearance
she said that one evening in the late 20
2017
after filming a video mr paul groped her
she forcefully
told him to stop and ran out of the room
lowly quit shortly after the
incident it was with jake i was with
jake for months
and i saw what kind of person was behind
the scenes and what kind of person he
put out to the rest of the world she
said
that actually corrupt i've seen him do
that kind of thing abe you've said to me
where he kind of just
he has this thing where he like gropes
girls he just grabs their
breasts she's 17 bro
you seen that right abi yeah i've seen
that yeah
he's done that like a couple times jake
obviously put out a statement like
literally everybody like i
i love this everybody's for um me too
and women's rights but no one is guilty
nobody's ever done anything
yeah but also man
i don't know what's interesting is that
somehow
investors continue to go back to
jake paul that's the so that's kind of
the conclusion of our article which i'm
coming to next
is that despite all of this and there
was big investors involved in team 10
it's like do you guys have no [ __ ]
decency
do you have no ethical obligation to
know what's going on in that house
i mean their money enabled all this [ __ ]
i mean you don't really need an article
to be written to see what was going on
it was happening in
in front of everyone according to young
turks jake paul's alleged victim justine
paradise is filing charges against jake
good for you
good for you girl doing something
because jake's been treating this girl
like [ __ ] and a lot of people have been
[ __ ] on her saying she's lying and
all this [ __ ]
and she's like [ __ ] you i'm going to the
police like like that
bravery
um this is jake's statement sexual
assault accusations are something that i
or anyone should ever take lightly
that being said this [ __ ] is a liar
[ __ ] her it's false
same statement copy paste every time
i am a champion of women's rights here's
the apology that everyone puts out
i am a champion of women's rights and i
have
supported and donated my time to women's
rights
that being said this this is slander
never done anything like this
but i believe women
not only if i had never had a sexual
relationship with this individual but
this claim is solely a manufacturer's
accusation of a blatant attempt for
attention exactly she's
clout chasing can we please stop
thinking that the clout chasing is
actually like that
that that's something that doesn't make
sense lives by
it's like his whole world pete davis is
after that clout
yeah i need that you can pay people by
tagging them
right that has never but like can we
just
dispel this notion that that's even a
thing she's not getting clout from this
she's getting
horrible especially jake is making this
post she's gonna get a ton of hate well
from
the beginning she was getting [ __ ] on
and hated on
keemstar was making all these statements
keemstar literally went on twitter and
he goes
can you give me that okay i actually
want to watch that one because now it's
super relevant but keemstar made this
twitter video he goes she's lying
because you can't get essayed in the
mouth like just close your mouth that's
what he said that was his take
that was the take of a grown-ass man i
can't talk about it because i don't want
to say something
i i can't handle this stuff
you can't he's so gross who keemstar
stuff yeah keemstar doesn't even talk
about it like what what kind of
statement
maybe you should go get therapy no maybe
someone should do that to him and then
we'll see him yeah give me your mouth
oh gross hilo that's why i'm saying i
can't even talk about him
i don't even want to go there i can't
talk about keemstar he's a disgusting
human being
jake paul sexually assaulted me in which
she claimed
that paul forced her to perform oral sex
on him in july of 2019
in his los angeles home now since then
and by the way she's planning on filing
charges against him
since then a second woman has come
forward and she has claimed that she was
also uh sexually assaulted by jake paul
she claims that when she was 17 years
old
okay i mean this is just information we
already know
here's the video just for you guys i
mean everyone knows keemstar is like
probably the worst person on the
internet
even despite everything and all we talk
about this isn't the first time he's
done it
he's the one person that tells the
victim oh you could have just said no
that's what he says in this video it's
like he missed it's like he
missed if he said it's at the 42nd mark
ish
this is him talking about the whole
because yeah let's not listen to him
talk for like
um several minutes this is a take in
2021 by
a [ __ ] i don't know late 30s with a
daughter by the way
seconds busted a nut in her mouth
and she claims that she was sexually
assaulted
now
how does that happen i'm like
wouldn't she have to open her mouth and
like participate
in some way for that to happen like
can't you just
turn your head or can't you just get
like
close your life is there that's what she
said there's a great way to force
oral sex on something i mean
she's not saying that he had a weapon
and was like you better do this
you know she is saying that he grabbed
her head
and started [ __ ] her face and came in
her mouth
i don't understand the physics here like
i don't understand how that's possible
like why
like i would can't you get away is there
really no way to get away
is there really no way to just close
your mouth like it just
not let the penis enter your mouth like
come on like i'm sorry
but i just don't believe this story at
all
i i just i am i'm missing something here
yes yes yes
challenge a lot of things challenge me
right really just
i don't want to go in front of millions
of people get called a victim blamer and
not have a piece of information uh that
i should have
um but like i don't believe it i don't
believe it
it sounds like bs please challenge me
i mean how do you want someone to
challenge you well he got challenged
he got challenged and he immediately was
like i never said anything like that and
like
just outright denied that he was didn't
he say on dramaalert that he doesn't
believe her
too and it's not the first time there
was a different girl that came out about
a different story
and he had to call her out too on his
platform which i still don't understand
why youtube and twitter and everyone
gives him a platform it was this guy
curtis something he apparently
essayed his what was it his girlfriend
and he goes
he this is the classic [ __ ] victim
blaming he goes
how can you essay your girlfriend or
wife am i getting that right i don't
want to speak at a turn here
i don't remember this story at all maybe
talk about it where's they be doing
research oh i'm here
yeah it was like in last summer right
yeah
yeah i believe yeah i believe that was
the situation but i'm not 100 sure
but that was his take where he's like
how can you essay your girlfriend
that's impossible as if they're just
[ __ ] dolls for you to
abuse and like there's no
anyway yeah it's obviously the worst
take i've ever heard in my life
and um he's a horrible human being he
really is
keemstar consistently amazes me you know
at this point it doesn't amaze me what
amazes me is youtube his twitter
is everyone that is allowing him to
spread this words to millions of people
oh we got a fresh tweet well i don't
know if you want to actually show it
because it
anyways basically yeah you're right
you're saying it's hard to believe
because your boyfriend and girlfriend
this is good here this is what he said
of that case you're talking about he
said
i hate cases of our word in most cases
only two people in the world actually
know what happened
everyone else has to guess the jesse
smiles and curtis story is so hard to
believe because they're a boyfriend and
girlfriend
so she says he r-worded her he went to
jail for it didn't he
i'm not i'll check right now but the
truth is none of us actually know what
happened okay douche
anyway yada yada jake paul keemstar
is the worst so in business land we're
wrapping up we're going to get to taylor
this was one that i
personally responded to i remember oh
where did i
said that me on discord i'll pull it up
it was like she should have just said no
he obviously has got some issue keemstar
has deeply rooted issues with women
because he always takes i mean his thing
is to like
either make fun of their appearance
including myself including abs
yeah i'm gonna have um or
call out victims calling them liars
and sending his fans to go attack them
and then he somehow like will do this
thing where he's like
i'm gonna donate a hundred dollars
everyone hashtag good guy kim to win
and then he gets that trending to make
it seem like
good guy game is a thing well whenever
you say i will tell you whenever you see
good guy keem trending and you just
click it it's all people
he's basically paying for it too too
the trend but anyway yeah keemstar
started this thing to say hilo looks
like a horse and uh
it was like basically he was just
tweeting pictures of horses to her i
mean which was
you know he's he's really he's yes epic
savage moments
um he is beyond uh incredibly
he's the worst i mean he's the worst
he's crazy
i'm gonna have a little bit of a rant
and i haven't researched everything so i
don't have all the details
coming out of the gate strong newsman
coming out the gates
so i'm gonna go on iran and i don't know
what i'm talking about i just don't know
oh can you hand me the the puppet if i'm
going to proceed i might as well go all
in here yeah people are surprised that
he made fun of baby's
beautiful wife yeah she did you called
her she called her the wicked witch she
started
um it's insane oh let me read your tweet
for no reason too
you're so insane oh no he he and he has
a this man has a daughter let's remind
you so
his his he obviously has some trauma
about his mom or something like that
um and obviously it's manifesting
himself and thinking
he really thinks women are i'm not sure
where it is oh really
it's got to be here somewhere we want to
find the public i don't want
to even go i haven't put so long about
this guy so
oh wow ela [ __ ] went off on kim she
said what a terrible dangerous take
victims of sexual assault already have a
hard enough speaking out
with feelings of shame and guilt the
last thing we need is for someone like
keemstar also criticized
how they should have just said no [ __ ]
gamestar
and that was how long ago already he's
still doing it
just last year still doing it
oh baby thank you uh we have keemstar
here to speak for himself on the matter
okay okay first of all ethan you are a
[ __ ] hypocrite okay
okay keemstar okay let me do this one
there you go
okay you're telling me why didn't you
just close your mouth
why didn't you just close your mouth i
mean it's impossible
to get essayed you just say no or you
just close your mouth
it's literally impossible
how would you know i've trust me i know
you do know look at my eyes
his eyes are all buggy and bloody here
let's watch this video
right but i just read a metoo movement
or me too statement
yeah we're almost done we're almost
right right we're almost done right
we're almost done
yeah okay i'm gonna have a little bit of
a rant and i haven't
researched everything so i don't have
all the details
so maybe there's something extra to this
story that i just don't know about
right we have there but i've read a me
too movement or me too statement
about these gamers they live in a gamer
house one's a guy one's a girl
the guy's drunk he jumps into her bed
he's like
putting his hand up against her chin he
like grabs her hand
kisses it he might say he grazes his
hand across her chest
and um the girl says i was so shocked by
all these three things that i just
didn't even react i was just i was i
just was froze i didn't
make total sense to me it's your
response when you get scared the girl
froze yeah they froze and that's scared
i think that happens of course to people
exactly what happened to that girl just
in paradise she's just and also
so with every women and men situation
there is a power difference so
what could you even do really every guy
almost 90
of guys will be stronger than the the
girl in that situation you're telling me
that
that girl in the jake paul situation
could have just moved him jake paul is
huge
well okay but he's ignoring the fact
that she says first of all
the girl says jake paul was holding her
head down forcefully
and she said it only lasted 20 seconds
and she was just in shock at what was
going on and like so yeah it makes total
sense
keemstar
douche star responsibility to say
something
if a guy is making moves on you and you
don't want that to happen you got to say
no
like that that's your responsibility you
have to say no
no it's the guy's responsibility not to
try to commit sex crimes on women it's
not their responsibility to [ __ ] be
ready at all times to swat away
predators
how is it their responsibility that's
not the society we're building that's
not a safe society we're building for
women where it's their responsibility
to protect themselves that's like victim
blaming one-on-one it's like oh you wore
sexy clothing so you had it coming yeah
that's such a weird take you can't just
not do anything and then be like
he wronged me what you gotta say no
you have to say no and what are we
talking about this
we're talking about kissing a hand
that's what we're saying no we're
talking about he got in bed and he gave
her unwanted touching it's [ __ ]
creepy people shouldn't
she shouldn't be have to deal with that
that's wrong to do
now if you would have said to him get
away from me and he still grabbed your
hand and kissed it fine
but when you say nothing nothing
no like hey you crossed the line hey too
much
and he just kisses your hand why don't
you pull your hand away
does it feel like he's defending himself
a little bit you know what i mean he's
like i've done [ __ ] like that
that's why he's like this he's like i've
done [ __ ] like this there's nothing
wrong with it like
he's like i've gone way worse yeah
exactly i've done way worse it's not a
crime
i feel totally fine about what i did i
mean maybe there's more details out
there that i just don't know about right
maybe there's more stories about all
these guys who are
attacking the victims it's because they
[ __ ] are defending themselves
they know they've done worse he is a
creep right but based on what i just
read and i didn't even read the full
thing because i couldn't get through it
because i was so angry
that this person's getting me tuned for
kissing a girl's hand
you the female have a responsibility to
say no no
stop i don't like this get away no you
have that responsibility
[Music]
i don't have all the details but if this
whole man's career is completely
finished and ruined
from kissing a girl's hand anyway he's
the worst person alive
case closed look into keemstar if you
don't know about him he's the worst
cheers
god bless so let me finish this and
we'll get taylor on the call
basically in business land and reaction
to jake paul
uh he continues to have new venture
funds
already lined up from powerful silicon
valley have agreed to contribute to the
fun
these older investors come in who have
no idea about social media
and they see he's got a lot of followers
and from their perspective it's a
success
mr mitchell said the real story is jake
should not be getting any money from
investors from the things he's done in
the past
where other youtubers like david dobrik
and james charles have faced financial
fallout after accusations of misconduct
mr paul has yet to see any consequences
if jake's sponsors and investors don't
hold him accountable
then why would he change any of his
actions
oh that's what paradise said just in
paradise so let's get taylor laurent
uh lorenz on the call here
who's been waiting patiently
and we will um there she is
hi taylor hi hi
sorry to keep you waiting oh no it's all
good
i'm here so um thank you for joining us
and thank you for writing this article i
think it is
great tell me
are you what was the what was the
process first of identifying like oh i
want to write this article about jake
and team 10 and all this
well i had been looking into this
article for over a month i started
talking to justine
before she put her video out on youtube
or anything
um so basically i mean jake has been
in the news a lot because um he has now
obviously raised a fresh
venture fund i think this is like his
third time trying to raise a venture
fund
and then obviously the boxing and all
that he's just gaining a lot of inroads
in the business world
and um you know from the new york times
we that's really interesting because we
want to look at the business and power
behind these creators and
i had written a lot about the team 10
house back in the day and um
you know obviously thomas petru and
other people were involved with team 10
that
that are part of these houses like hype
house and stuff um
and so and there's just all these kids
that want to move into these houses and
be like jake paul
so i just kind of started to look into
um
you know the world that he built and
what it was like for that first
generation of kids that
moved into you know these collab houses
how did you find this this uh this
boy who was 14 did you because i i never
saw him i didn't even know about him i
was really surprised to hear his story
um how did you connect with him
yeah well i began reaching back out to
people who were there from the first
days like the early days of team 10. so
back in 2016
when jake raised money um you know
team time let's not forget you know
investors backed team 10.
they put a lot of money behind it wasn't
just jake's money he
doesn't usually spend his own money he
can help it so
um so i started reaching back out to
people but um i had gotten basically
connected with him
um through a mutual connection who said
that he was ready to talk and
um yeah i remembered him because he was
14
and then alex launched was like 15.
there was a bunch of like really young
people
um when jake launched that first version
of team town obviously team 10 cycled
through so many people over the years
how is it that how is it that investors
were
okay backing up such a project that has
no
accountability for anything they're
clearly not taking care of the kids i
mean
and then they i mean it was all easy to
see that they're up to no good
they were always in the news getting
into trouble with the neighborhood
i know i mean i was there the day that
you know when that
reporter showed up and jake paul was
wreaking havoc and everything
i think the issue is is that and it's
two things i mean one there are these
really toxic investors and men in
silicon valley that i think
see themselves in jake paul they don't
give a you know they don't give a care
in the world to the stuff that he's done
um and then there's a lot of people that
i think are just kind of vaguely
ignorant or they don't really care like
jake still has reach and
one thing that's been really interesting
i'm sure you guys have seen but in the
past
year there's just been so much attention
from silicon valley on the sort of
quote-unquote creator world where
they're just
desperate to back these people they like
just discovered that people are big on
youtube
suddenly i think and they don't really
know who to back and so they go
google you know youtube star and they
see jake paul and they're like oh okay i
guess he's popular maybe their kids
watch him
um i find it interesting there seems to
be no due diligence i mean these are
investors they know
they know something about due diligence
that's their whole world right they need
to
they need to thoroughly investigate
where they're putting their money
i'm sure investigating like a company is
a lot harder than
looking up that jake paul is is a
is a problematic person to put it mildly
you know i find that interesting
um and even now like you said he's just
raised another
from some of the most powerful people in
silicon valley i mean
and chris dixon personally put money
into this fund
they personally put money in this is
after jake spent you know all last year
partying during kovitz saying it's a
hoax
you know among other things it's not
like it's a secret that jake is
is toxic um but you know i will say that
good investors do do you dylan's i mean
and you know at least um
you know david dobrik you know met with
other vc funds and they watched i think
two of his videos and we're like this is
a liability
oh interesting yeah so
yeah that is interesting because you
know before all this stuff came to like
david dobrik was
i think considered obviously his
content was mature but like
non-controversial
i think it's just like it depends on the
investor's risk too
like some of these investors are more
risk prone i think the ones that
don't get it actually it's really
shocking from the outside like i think
that
we watch a lot of pranks we've seen
david dobrik's videos over there it's
almost normalized to us but i think
if you have an older guy that's not
really online look at it it's like oh
that that just looks like drama or
liability or someone's going to get hurt
you know right you know you know what's
interesting to me it seems like all
these
investments not what is panned out from
these investments
dyspo is in flames
jake paul team 10 i don't think they
ever made money from that
why do people even keep giving creators
money because i haven't seen any
evidence of a huge return
i think because they see creators
themselves making a lot of money
so they're trying to find a way in on
this and let's not i mean jake paul had
an
app too i don't know if you guys
remember locker room his social media
app
that he tried that kept men and women
separate which
whoa no i don't remember that yeah well
oh and then you just reminded me of
another one of jake paul's ventures
which was basically
more or less a scam where he was selling
how to be an influencer
you remember that that was true it's
like nothing none of his ventures have
been successful so i just want like with
a track record like that and
and then all of the toxic behavior it
surprised me that anyone will give him
money
i think it's like a way to i think it's
a signaling right like i think that like
these investors like mark andres and
chris dixon that are putting their
personal money in there i think it's a
way to kind of be like yeah you know i'm
supporting this guy like i'm cool
like oh really i think that they like i
mean i think they know he's problematic
they don't care
sure i think but listen to like i mean i
don't know how much you guys talked
about this but like
you know charlie and dixie and a ton of
people were out promoting his fight just
last weekend on tick tock like there's a
lot of people that don't
care or don't yeah well i think it's all
about public perception with these kinds
of things where it's like
you know it look there's a fight with
him and it's huge event so it must be
fine
you know yeah yeah i don't think these
people think about it too much
is there anything like is there anything
i
left out i i'm i'm assuming you were
watching when i was reading about the
article
was there anything that i left out that
you thought was important to mention
yeah i i kind of cut out for part of it
so i'm not sure if you mentioned but i
just want to say
that you know the new york times
fact-checking process is incredibly
intense and um you know it's
it's it's a long process we started
talking to justine a long time ago far
before she ever went to the press like
before she ever posted her video and um
you know i interviewed other people
including people that were there
that corroborated her account of events
um
you know we really do due diligence so i
think sometimes people see things and
they
they take it as just like a drama or
that person's just saying stuff and it's
like this was a
this was a really long process there was
a lot that came out there was a lot that
didn't even make it in there that i'm
sure we'll end up
on the internet but i think um
you know it was it was intense um
so what do you think about keemstar's
defense that it's a that she should have
just closed her mouth
closed her mouth i mean why i love how
he prefaces something with like i don't
really know what's going on
that's the best read the full article
but that's what i think
i i think that's so incredibly offensive
and also to say that these women didn't
say
no or make it clear that it was
unacceptable it's also just
counter factual you know these women do
say no and nick paul is a boxer he's a
big intimidating person i mean
it's not like you know you were saying
like you know women are not always
in in this position and i'm i i have to
say like um
you know it's very brave and unusual for
for justine to come out i think she
really gave like a very like
measured account on the video but we i
spoke to her at length and
her sole motivation it was just to kind
of prevent other this
from happening to other women and that's
really why she wanted to talk about it
um
you know she doesn't care about the
investors or whatever like she just
doesn't want other women to have to go
through what she went through and
that's something we've touched on before
which is like the one of these
unfortunate side effects of dealing with
something like this as a victim is that
now all of a sudden not only have you
been a victim and you have to hold the
trauma of that
but now you've you may feel as a victim
that you have now all of a sudden this
responsibility
because you need you need to to let
other people know and it's like
so so not only are they um committing
this crime on you but now they're giving
you guilt associated with
having to speak up and prevent it from
happening from other people
it's so messed up and i also just hope
that more
you know reporters in the mainstream
media cover this stuff i think a lot of
stuff
gets written up as like drama like i was
just looking at
the best when justine first put her
piece out and it's just it's framed as
like drama coverage and like
you know this is this is it's a crime
yeah it's a crime and it's serious and
it should be covered that way and
um so i just i i hope that that you know
that
kind of can be reframed
that's a good point yeah i think i think
people get too caught up
with exactly like you said or if it's on
the internet it's youtube drama
or because she chose to tell her story
on youtube
um i mean we we knew that she was going
to publish that before she went
before our story would come out because
our story was taking a while and she
i think really wanted to speak out on it
also just in her own voice but it's like
just because you choose youtube to tell
your story doesn't mean that it's
youtube drama it just
that's a platform for you to have a
voice and for her to say stuff that she
could never say
in an article you know we don't it's a
the article can only be so long right
like she really wants to tell
everything so there's no question so
it's
interesting how there's almost like a
built-in defense
when people like jake they invite a girl
like her who's like a small influencer
and so no matter what she ever says they
have this built-in defense that she's
just clout chasing
yeah that's like what you always hear
from everyone is oh they're just doing
this for clout
um is that a thing what is what does it
mean to clout chase as a victim
is that something that you can gain
clout not a thing right no you don't get
any clout from it i mean
yeah i can tell you as somebody that's
reported on
a lot of horrible stuff over the years
the people
who experience this stuff usually just
have lasting trauma and it's
much it's harder for them you know
they're not going to get brand deals as
easily
they're sort of forever synonymous with
this horrible event on the internet it's
very hard for them to change their image
they obviously get so much hate
from people like keemstar that are
questioning their situation with no
understanding of what's going on
um and so it's it's really hard for it's
so
like cloud chasing is just such an
idiotic way to frame
something like that and it also like
puts him on this pedestal where
i think if you're saying oh this
person's cloud chasing then you're
acknowledging that you were in a
position of power with this person
and like i mean i think that's almost
telling on yourself a little bit
interesting that's very true yeah
well i agree um yeah i hope that more
women speak out too and i hope that the
media can cover it more like i hope that
i hope that more women consider going to
like reporters and stuff because i will
say that like
you know vetting it and having speaking
to the other people like speaking to her
friends speaking to people that were
like familiar with the situation that
saw her
you know crying afterwards and stuff
like there's just a lot that i think
um it's like hard for people to get when
she tells her own story but i think
i don't know yeah i agree i mean and it
unfortunately gets taken
like you said as drama when you don't
really speak to a reporter
but if you go to a reporter then it's
like a serious story
for some reason
yeah like pay attention to it like i
think that like the cmo of
target or whatever might not see your
youtube video but
they'll certainly know if you talk to
the new york times whatever that's
not to say you shouldn't do both you
know you can do vote you can put stuff
on the internet and you can talk to the
media
yeah well when i first saw justine's
video i was like wow
i never heard anyone really describe
their assault in such detail before
and i thought from the beginning that
she was being
really brave and coming forward and she
immediately got hate from a lot of
people like keemstar and other people
online
and um yeah i think it's
i think it's brave and i'm glad that
there are people in the new york times
and such established organizations that
are willing
to examine these kinds of things and to
acknowledge that it's not like new it's
not
you know people don't take this this
realm so seriously but now all of a
sudden
you know they're serious actors here
like with all that jake paul is doing
and the venture capital and the boxing
and
these are big players now all of a
sudden and they need to be treated as
such
definitely i mean insider's done a great
job with that as well i know they
covered like all the jeffree star stuff
too
like these people are running million
dollar businesses in some cases like
some of these creators and
these investors and so i think hopefully
more reporters will look into it and
more more people will
also come forward with stuff um but it
just it just sucks it sucks that these
people have to deal with these haters on
the internet because it's like
it's it's a lot of like nine-year-olds
too that just happened right of course
right
yeah of course well
taylor thank you for sharing with us
thank you for calling in and
helping us understand all this and um
keep up the good work i'm a fan of yours
i've followed oh likewise well thanks
for you know covering all this stuff
yeah thank you so thank you taylor
taylor lauren's on
that's just your handle right on twitter
yep we'll put a link in the description
if you guys want to follow
follow taylor on twitter she's always
bringing uh
scoops and news so we'll put that in the
description thank you taylor thank you
for calling in
thanks guys appreciate it bye take care
hmm thanks guys bye
oh was that delayed or she okay there we
go
i think that was a really interesting
point she says about the clout
i think the more the cloud chasing
people oh yeah that was really good yeah
like when have you ever seen a famous
victim
that like became famous when i was
hanging up on her i think i accidentally
reported her to zoom
for like a crowd good job so sorry
just reported you to zoom thank you i
hope you don't get banned or something i
don't know how that works
yeah i'm sorry what were you saying that
like if that was a thing you would have
like
people who became famous just from from
being a victim of oh yeah
that has never happened she justine
paradise famously made her big break
from her accusations against jake paul
in 2021
since then she's skyrocketed to fame
there you go taylor lorenz everybody
yeah it's pretty amazing that you can be
such a like
like all of his tech ventures have been
such colossal failures
i i'm actually surprised that he's still
failing up baby it's the best way to get
ahead in this country he continues to
make money for himself but i don't see
any of his like uh
investment opportunities panning out i
want to give jake paul a [ __ ] even if
he wasn't talks i wouldn't give him a
[ __ ] dollar
oh man i can turn your one dollar into
zero by the end of the year
guaranteed look at my track record i
mean the
the fight did bring in a lot of money
yeah but they're not investing in the
fight
that's jake paul's money uh right he's
the investor in that case you're right
yeah nobody's benefiting from that i'd
say jake
i mean that's just that's just his
direct creator opportunities
it's like yeah jake makes a lot of money
but that's the money he makes for doing
his
[ __ ] stick right nobody's cutting you
in on that action
anyway that's jake paul for you with a
little spice of keemstar's a douche
which is always a nice spice
to sprinkle on any meal
ben shapiro is a
speaking of douches ben shapiro
wet ass p word i was waiting for it so
that was coming
so this is not a parody okay
uh ben shapiro who what's the backstory
for this in georgia
a bunch of companies are moving out of
georgia because they're
enforcing these like absolutely heinous
voter
suppression laws and where's the whole
video this is just the i want the right
below yeah
good people are saying it was out of
context so she posted the whole thing
and it's like
here we are just as you know um so home
depot is
like one of the only big companies in
georgia that was like we're not gonna
comment on this
is that right then right yeah they're
just uh
they're based in georgia and they uh
are trying to remain neutral they're
remaining neutral
but a lot of the big companies are
pulling out of georgia and they're like
you know [ __ ] [ __ ]
or maybe not necessarily pulling out of
georgia but their uh
their lobbying against the law in
some fashion or another what is the
issue so in georgia because they lost
because they went blue
the government and power there is trump
is in
enacting like some very severe
voter suppression laws to prevent uh you
know
black people yeah in in short black
people from voting
right so ben shabino is out here
oh here maybe thank you just to give you
an idea uh
the the governor brian kemp just signed
into a law bill that adds many obstacles
to voting including reducing the number
of ballot boxes
shrinking the window for early voting
adding additional photo id requirements
and allowing state officials to
circumvent the work of county election
officials if they don't like the
outcomes they are seeing
the georgia bill even goes so as far as
to make it illegal for outside groups to
give water or food to voters stuck in
long lines
you know where there's long lines in
poor and poor mostly black neighborhoods
okay
illegal to give food and water to people
stuck in long lines
i mean this [ __ ] is straight up jim crow
[ __ ]
backwater racist [ __ ]
oh hit me with that tucker laugh
lunatic how do people defend this how
how do people of defenders we are
witnessing right now a massive and
unabashed assault on voting rights
unlike anything we've seen since the jim
crow era yeah
how do you defend removing ballot boxes
yeah well they say they do it all under
the guise of
voter fraud which there's basically zero
of
so you know and if you know good on i
think good on the companies
they have a right it's so ironic these
republicans cannot get their opinions
straight
they lobby their whole [ __ ] career to
give businesses more power
and then the moment they actually use
that authority that they fought their
whole career to
to uh to give them then all of a sudden
boycotting is
is canceled culture so here's ben
shapiro
i haven't i have not seen evidence of
ben shapiro being smart to be on frank
with you guys
i mean he talks fast and he's articulate
but his takes don't make any sense yeah
there's no consistency let's see
here we are at home depot as you know
controversy has now involved home depot
as people are encouraging people to
boycott home depot because home depot is
not getting involved
in georgia there's a voter law
controversy from people doing exactly
the right thing
because after all they are in fact home
depot they are not in fact
in the business deposit because you
should be buying from companies that are
not falling to the world left
home depot so far is one of those
companies so here's what we're doing
i encourage you to do the same we're
gonna go in there i'm gonna buy some
stuff
so wait watch this watch this it gets so
good
all right as you can see he bought a
wood
he bought a wood this is him supporting
home depot
i went and bought a wood and i put it in
a bag in a bag
what is he gonna do with that wood do
you think oh my god
hi i'm ben shapiro and i just went to
home depot and i bought a woods
like i'm going to go build a house for a
home i'm going to go help with homeless
shelter buy something out for your
support
i bought this piece of wood yes home
depot supporters
everybody
you couldn't come up with anything more
sad than this well here that's why
everyone's making fun of him right here
shopping at home depot you should do the
same this one
this board this magnificent piece poplar
is now mine
here we are at home depot how is this
not a joke such a gun
yeah this is the job right as you can
see i just went shopping
[Music]
he's doing social justice right now one
would plank at a time
oh also one thing people pointed out
which is pretty funny
is that he's standing on the curb to
make himself look taller
all right as you can you see how it's
shot here's the curb
and here's the street when you're as
when you're a little bit my whole life
trying to
not even physically but like you know
just spiritually
you spend your whole life working on
camera angles like that
figuring out
but that was slick i didn't even notice
that he was standing on a curve until
someone pointed it out
extra large and extra hard
a group of uh i love that i can't get
over this
piece of wood so just give you a little
context how do you go to home depot and
only come out with a piece
of wood how is that helping home depot
yeah
i encourage everybody to go buy he's
like i'm gonna go buy a bunch of stuff
the hope home depot
here's one piece of wood i'm gonna throw
in the dumpster on the way out thank you
fun funny enough i happened to go to
home depot for the first time my life
and just get a piece of wood yesterday
but
is there something completely unrelated
wow
solidarity with ben shapiro you are pro
georgia
voting restrictions
well funnily of course because ben is
such a hypocrite and he can't
keep one talking point straight from the
other i wonder if all of his fans just
went and bought a piece of wood now
i doubt it maybe maybe there's just wood
planks and bags all over america
ben shapiro who's a giant hypocrite and
can't keep his talking points straight
tweeted previously i cancelled my sports
illustrated subscription after 16 years
last year because of the leftist
politics
all right i think he's trying to cancel
sports illustrated
i think they had like a trans i remember
this they had like a trans model
and so he thought that was a political
statement and cancelled his
sports illustrated
these people are oh here's a great one
from ben shapiro this was from his vlog
that he's tried to scrub from the
internet because he knows he's such a
[ __ ]
just
so apparently he's calling on a boycott
of
ritz crackers because of
al sharpton uh what is the thing here
sharpton had used the term cracker uh
disparagingly about white people in like
1990 or something
and he's uh he's holding on to that well
because he's he had a
he i think maybe still does has a show
on msnbc
so he was calling for a boy ritz was one
of the sponsors
of his show so he says if you disagree
with ritz crackers that sharpton's
program is dis
tasteful believable and generally
acceptable in terms of social and
community standards
if you do not think that sharpton's
brand is of divisive
blah blah anyway he goes contact ritz
crackers please sign the petition
and call on everybody here's the phone
number here's the tweet here's the
hashtag
hashtag sharptonscrackers please at ritz
carlton i'm sorry who's doing cancel
culture
this is like a whole organized
oh god this is like high level cancel
[ __ ]
i'm so sick of the [ __ ] term cancel
culture it's so
[ __ ] meaningless it doesn't mean
anything it doesn't mean anything well
especially when they do it all the
[ __ ] time
and like donald trump we just invented
boys
or boycotting in the last like four
years this is
boycotting has existed forever like this
is so stupid it's not bad
well yeah i think it's it's just a
republican tactic to [ __ ] rile people
up because it's like okay
you mean you could say and cancel yeah
you don't have to make sense anyway
bench bureau bought a plank of wood
that's the point i love that
i'll never look at planks of wood this
time here is my piece of wood
hold up that wood let me see your wood
again maybe yeah maybe let's give me
that wood
let me take at that from home depot yeah
let me get it out
let me see he's got to get the wood up
can you get a bag
i know i didn't use a bag can you have a
bag can we just put it in a bag
i may have i may have a home depot bag
you got to wrap up that wood dude yeah
you better bag that you gotta
you're gonna get a splinter you gotta be
safe [ __ ] let's be safe and wrap the
wood
back of the wood uh there's a britney
spears update ela you can give me your
opinion on this
okay for the first time brittany has
answered the question on everybody's
mind
yet it still raises more questions than
answers yet again
and so you tell me this what you think
i'm here to answer all of your questions
and the first main question that you
guys have been asking me is basically
when i'm in my living room
do i get dizzy when i'm spinning so much
yes i get extremely dizzy
um i'm a dancer so as long as i have a
focus point for my head
um as i turn as long as i keep finding
that spot usually in the end it's not as
bad
um the second question that you guys
have been asking me is basically
what does the red refrigerator mean on
my instagram
honestly i just thought it was cool i
thought it was vintage it was red
and am i um
yes i'm totally fine i'm extremely happy
i have a beautiful home beautiful
children
um i'm taking a break right now because
um
i'm enjoying myself that's it okay she
always does that cut off
weirdly and the bouncing yeah
nervousness
her instagram is the most bizarre
instagram i've ever seen i i follow her
because it's so bizarre
yeah i think all of us to be honest but
she says am i okay
yes i'm fine but um people are not so
sure in the comments people are still
worried about brittany
um people are saying
[Music]
people are saying the first time she's
ants
okay she says the way she keeps looking
to the side and strange cuts don't sit
right with me hmm
she keeps looking to the side and
swaying hmm
you answer am i okay but we know this
still isn't you honey
hmm i don't know
who was asking these questions
so there you go there's still skepticism
is brittany okay
we we will never know
like maybe a little alone a little over
analyzing
yeah i feel like that's like a past time
at this point
is decoding her instagram videos whole
instagram is weird so i think the
conclusion is that she is just weird
hey hey
she's got kind of i mean with peace and
love this is just my first thing that
came to my head i don't know you might
you guys might want to [ __ ]
run me over but i looks like she's on
something
the way she's bouncing um
some kind of stimulant you know that
kind of bouncing
when you ever bounce like that
there has been a conservative
conservatorship update though
yeah jamie her dad's lawyer say that
jamie would like to
end the conservatorship really but here
you go here's this [ __ ]
he would love nothing more than to see
britney not need a conservatorship
whether or not there is an end to the
conservatorship really depends on
brittany
okay douche if she wants to end her
conservatorship she can file a petition
to end it like any parent he doesn't
always see eye to eye on what brittany
may want okay she's like literally 40
years
ago that she wants to end it but your
your authority as a parent has long
expired she's a [ __ ] like grown ass
adult
but jamie believes every single decision
he has made has been in her best
interest yeah
especially the part where you got a
raise you kept giving yourself raises
yeah was that part of what was in her
best interest just
end this thing brittany's lawyer asked
for temporary conservator jody
montgomery to be named permanent
conservator jody stepped in as temporary
conservator in september after jaime
stepped down due to health reasons
court documents say that brittany
reserves the right to petition for the
termination of the conservatorship
brittany has previously said in court
documents she strongly opposes having
her dad as her conservator
and strongly prefers jody in that role
okay so why can't we just do it already
he's like hey i would love to hey i'm
ready to step down you know it's just
when britney's
you know when the court deems brittany
healthy
it's the whole situation so can we get
to leave brittany alone in the chat
hey speaking of leave brittany alone
this is an interesting super chat that
just came through
uh fun fact chris crocker who was the
leave brittany alone person
uh just sold an nft i'm assuming of that
meme
for forty thousand dollars wow
amazing and cashing in on the uh
on the old meme so he sold the video i i
don't actually know it it didn't specify
what the nft was uh
that's what i mean that's he he went
viral for that
i don't so i imagine it had something to
do with that here we got the link here
man who knew that he would be cashed in
on this maybe it was britney spears
like two decades later that was so long
ago let's see i'm alone
still don't know what it means because
okay i mean i sold one for 60 000
so who am i for 19 eth
pretty good not bad dude leave brittany
alone
carlos needs some money he should he
should sell the big connect meme
oh the car right disappeared for me
the comments the chat i turned it off
during the
it was becoming quite unruly and toxic
and also
wait what were people saying they're not
i thought it was just my computer being
weird
wait what happened what were they saying
you guys need to [ __ ] behave dude
what were they saying then there uh
there
was a lot of um arguing going on
about um the validity of
the allegations against jake paul
there's people here watching this show
that think that
she should have just closed her mouth um
that's incredible i didn't know that i'd
like to have one of those people call in
and discuss
no what i want to hear them
what is their discussion i want to hear
their logic i want to know who these
people are
aren't you curious you don't entertain
those people
dude i don't know i'm curious i want to
hear what the like how can your brain
opera like you know what i mean
after all this they still think you know
i'm gonna find that interesting
i mean obviously i'm gonna disagree with
them
well i banned most of them so i'm not
going to be able to find them so
then and they're not going to be able to
speak up do you care about
mike madd magelick and lana rhodes
no well actually
mike mike lick
get it well anyway lana dumped him he's
a douche
and um but actually david pork boy who
is an enemy of the show
had lana on and there was kind of a
funny encounter from it
um pork boy and his 18 year old friend
who they have this podcast
um and they're super rude they were like
super rude to trisha
they're super rude to lana the whole
time um
these guys it's just a super trashy show
but there was a point at the end where
he's like oh well you can leave her hang
around and then they can
they just ignore her for the rest of the
show you can
you can sit around uh or you can balance
we just do
sections but like what do you mean
balance can you plan your [ __ ] a little
bit
okay so now uh you can bounce at this
point i mean
i guess i can kind of see like
maybe they thought maybe she would want
to stay and like talk about whatever
they were talking about
well you should discuss that ahead of
time right my first
problem with this is why are they
sitting so close they're sitting on a
little table and they have notes and
[ __ ] it's super
[ __ ] why is he sitting so close to
her
it's inappropriate you sitting so close
to her well i think i have to crowd to
be on camera
get another camera
um we famously had an incident just like
this that people criticized
us for years before so maybe well
whatever that was
better now yeah but you can't understand
where
that might happen sometimes it happens
well regardless okay who cares it's
funny i mean whatever
okay i'm not perfect all right what is
going
on with you
at least william wasn't on camera the
whole time well that was the whole point
is that we knew it would be awkward and
so we had him step outside
but look at her anything we handled it i
guess we did handle it a little better
dude regarding the william thing i'm
pretty sure i said to him beforehand
like we're going to do this
briefly and we're going to we don't have
to relitigate it
why are you bringing it up can we focus
on the fact that he got her to sit so
close
to him well i'll tell you what else he
made her play a game
[ __ ] mary kill with logan mike and him
i was like what is wrong with you
brother the fact that he
set the situation to sit so close to her
no dave
pork boy is a total creep you guys are
talking about out of stuff and i can't
get over this why are they sitting so
close
actually yeah there's a lot more space
on that couch he's clearly trying to
like
yeah when he's a little when he made her
play [ __ ] mary kill and she handled it
great she didn't even answer him
she goes i would definitely kill logan
and [ __ ] my ex-boyfriend she didn't even
include his
creepy broke or well he's not he's
actually quite rich
but like broke spiritually i don't like
him
horrible vibes but like
you know and he recently had like a sex
take leave oh i mean it was consensual
but he was like spitting on her and had
her on like a leash and was
like choking her and [ __ ] i read wait
what i'm doing
at all does anybody know about that dave
pork boy had a sex tape
yeah yes he had a sex tape i'm not sure
about all those details i mean
i haven't heard about those details i
saw him talking about it on twitter
and he said like yes i was spitting on
her and choking her but it was like i'm
just [ __ ] dude i'm just doing my
thing it was consensual
she likes consensual yeah but who wants
to watch
that i mean [ __ ] what did he release it
or did it no
i just don't like him you guys i'm not
much i've gathered
i don't like him either i gotta can you
guys scrub and find that [ __ ] marry kill
part because it's so awkward and she
handled it so good
you know this whole interview they
treating her like because she's a porn
star she has no [ __ ]
like uh right to
like there's one part where she says
someone was making her feel
uncomfortable
when he was like feeling her hair and
[ __ ] and then they watched the clip and
they're like oh he didn't do anything
wrong like well
you know they get this notion that
because she's a sex worker she can't be
assaulted
and you get that vibe very much
throughout this video yeah that she's
gonna go on a date with him after the
show
we talk [ __ ] about lana i don't remember
talking [ __ ] about lana
baby said you [ __ ] do you talk [ __ ]
about lana
i didn't talk [ __ ] about lana i mean
no i you weren't trying to be uh mean
but
there was some discussion about if you
made a porn star that's all i remember
yeah we'll go with that what is that
what go ahead you brought it up let's
hear it
i just uh how stretched out she is and
oh
oh yeah you said really awful things
about it right now right i never forgot
about that
no that was that was old me i'm
enlightened now
thanks baby i tried to
i mean he was trying to avoid it ruined
my relationship with that one picture
that he posted
which was what i don't know what's going
on okay so she's trying to like get it i
got a facetime the other day
and i'm just sitting in my room and he's
like i need scissors and i'm like why do
you need scissors and you won't tell me
so he comes in i i regret it i don't
remember what i said but that sounds
[ __ ] up
yeah i think we were having some debate
about like if for
you know whatever we don't need to
recover listen i'm a douche i
embrace that anything else any other
dirty laundry you want to bring up a b
no this was before frenemies trisha
exactly yeah
you can't blame me for anything that
happened before because i'm full it's
true
i am fully enlightened now i've i mean
i've come a long way
i think to be totally honest
trisha has taught me a lot
anyway that's that okay did you guys
find the [ __ ] mary kill part
yeah actually like lana i think she's
cool like
from what i've seen about her in the
videos with mike
she's the reason that guy has any
[ __ ] drop of success is because she's
like he really mistreated her yeah from
the things that i'm
gathering just i haven't looked too much
into it but it
seems kind of like a dish oh yeah
totally well she explains that like she
bought a house for them and she was
really serious about the relationship
and then he was like
right before they were about to move in
and he committed to moving in with her
he goes oh by the way i'm making a
[ __ ]
hype house with faze banks and uh who
was the other person
i don't recall somebody somebody equally
cringes yeah
and i so now i'm moving in with them and
she's like what she's like [ __ ] you
but she apparently was having like cyber
sex with somebody on gta 5 and it made
her really upset
it was like really graphic role-playing
cyber sex what the [ __ ] man
and he was doing it on the stream and
she's like that really upset me i don't
like how you did that
and then these guys are like oh come
like because she's a sex worker it's
like oh come on like come on
yeah it's like look she's she's right
she's not entitled to
um want her boyfriend to be loyal to her
exactly
i mean but it's like simulated really uh
intense role-playing so here's
here is dave pork boy trying to slide in
with lana
mary kell we put this together late it's
logan paul
mike magellan and dave the fact that he
included himself is so profoundly creepy
so profoundly creepy and she handles it
like this
and then me now i have an undeniable
photo here so
so see this is what i wanted for us to
wear for like
all the miami yeah look at her body
posture bro she's so not into
stretching away from me you can't be any
further away
i don't have that [ __ ] here dave this is
kind of unfair because the shirt that
you put yourself
in you literally picked like the most
sexy picture of you and then you have
them fully dressed
for the record i didn't pick the photos
i had nothing to do with it we didn't
have a game
logan's wearing tux which i think that's
the best a guy right
mike kind of got [ __ ] because he's
just wearing normal you guys gave mike
the worst
so i i would i'd marry me
[Music]
that's a no-brainer for me because i
think highly myself
yeah i think i think i'll marry dave he
could
he could support my lifestyle oh those
guys could too
um wait she said that she would marry
dave okay because he yeah i missed that
part
probably have to kill logan and [ __ ] my
ex yeah
i think that was probably the safe
answer she didn't really play though
i can't get over the fact that he hosts
with the 18 year old
holy [ __ ] i was sweating i was sweating
for a little bit yeah
you know maybe the safe answer actually
would have been
marry logan 19.
there you have it we're not gonna watch
that other clip
i found that other one way funnier which
one highlight it the one of uh mike
on his stream he calls her on stream
because she
said at some point that i guess she
doesn't consider
that she was in a fake relationship with
him and he's like wait what oh yeah
yeah here what's going on today
[Music]
from somebody who knows better than
[ __ ] anybody this [ __ ] is completely
blacked out
i mean come like like like
i'm not bro she's just not into anymore
you know how you see those models of the
solar system
like is this supposed to be time stamp
this is eight minutes uh yeah i don't
it was supposed to be this is where it
starts it's
i should just watch from here like realm
of
of the universe she doesn't even know
what [ __ ] planet she's on right now
okay so how was it dinner tonight
amazing it was good
yeah i'm sure my desserts if you don't
mind me asking you you said you were
coming out
as what i i heard something lesbian
[ __ ] news to me
that's it man that's like the most
dramatic thing a guy can deal with
[Laughter]
when did this happen it's been a while
it's been a minute
fake youtube relationship i'm sorry what
was that
i'm sorry what okay
people are like what yeah mike you just
got an owned man
but after hearing that story i get why
she says that
like she [ __ ] hates him she was
planning for you guys to move together
and you're just on the day of the move
on the day they were supposed to move he
told her he's going in another house
type house with faze banks it sounds
like it was it sounds like it was like
yeah it makes her feel like it was fake
yeah right and by the way he benefited
greatly from that relationship like he
benefited so greatly from that
relationship
um
yep i'm sorry what was that
he calls her live yeah this
by the way he gotten do we know if this
whole
r word thing with logan paul happened or
not it's so confusing i'm pretty
skeptical that it did really
we haven't confirmed okay so i won't
even talk there is no footage of it
anywhere
so i saw okay so there was some story
about him calling logan live and i'll
tell him
logan said something offensive but
there's been no corroboration of it so i
don't think
as for now i have no problem what is the
shitty move of calling someone live
you can't do that yeah how about you
call if you have a question about your
relationship how do you put you down
when you're not streaming
trying to monetize your relationship in
every single [ __ ] possible way
hey i just out of curiosity did you say
that we were in a fake youtube
relationship
on uh kevin wong's video yeah what
happened
why did you oh you don't know i was
really intoxicated
was it a fake youtube relationship but i
honestly have no idea where that came
from oh you're on stream right now by
the way i should tell you
oh by the way
how do people endure him i don't know i
don't know
yep we need to make a left tearless
ricegum vin diesel
mike chucker
[Music]
[Laughter]
well apparently you said you didn't care
about but now we're interested
yeah i guess they didn't care about it
oh so here's another fun one
so mike is trying to get lana in his
videos because they only get views when
she's in it
and then she goes you got to start
paying me to be in your [ __ ] videos
how many millions of dollars have you
made off my of me
she says well i'm not going to be in
your vlog without payment period you
can't
she sent this on she shared this on
instagram you can't record me without
getting something
how much is the bag probably 4 500. dude
that's so much
do you guys want to have me on your show
you're so poor
no i don't lo i'm the best guest ever i
was talked over by you for a year
i don't know why i would sign up for a
whole hour of it
and so many people would watch
yeah yeah i don't think yeah that's the
not mad laugh right there
alfredo 4 500 that's awesome
i gotta say i am team lana
on this one guys i'm gonna show up the
audience alfredo
real quick i got a haircut oh freako got
a haircut
look at this guy alfredo
he's the best dog ever i know it was you
freedom
i know it was you
ready you're so sweet
i know jake and logan very well this was
interesting too apparently after they
broke up
everybody blocked her including logan
which is like some real frat boy
[ __ ] insane weird [ __ ] you ever heard
anything like this i know jake and logan
very well
um i wouldn't i wouldn't actually logan
has to be blocked on everything right
now not because
this but just after the breakup mike
blocked me
and all my friends and made his friends
block me okay it was a block off
i didn't i did absolutely some little
middle school [ __ ] yeah go a little
faster
when did you finish middle school didn't
that guy just like finish middle school
like a couple years ago
yeah some real medical [ __ ] i would know
i remember very well
take it from me
oh nothing i just broke up with him and
he blocked me on everything what was the
official reason for the breakup by the
way
because because i'm gonna be honest that
they want different things kind of
sounds like just
and the rumor was very much you told me
it was fake that you that he was hitting
on a girl in like a video game or
something no no that wasn't true
that that was a whole nother scenario oh
so that happened just that's not why
y'all broke up
no that's not why we broke up so he was
live on like gta you know like the
servers
but it's like real girls on the other
end and he was having virtual sex with
them but you didn't care about that
no i i cared like it's real girls and
like you're like
getting ahead from them and you're like
yeah [ __ ] suck my dick like
of course virtually virtually yeah but
it's a real person it's not like it's
just a simulation
so you're happy yeah i know he can't
deal with this he's like but you're okay
with that right
yeah it's just virtual he's like he's
like
wait how do you do this yeah where do
you
he's streaming and i'm watching it
traumatized oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] how did he how did he think he
wasn't gonna get caught but this isn't
why you said he broke up no it's not why
we broke up i did have a massive issue
with it but he said he would never do it
again so i'm like okay
fine and we've had plenty of issues our
fair share of issues of him being
inappropriate with other women but
that's besides the point
we officially broke up because he
finally told me
i got a house for us actually and he
told me he was going to move in with me
broke up with me the day that he was
supposed to move in that was another
time
and then the second time he told me he
was going to move in with me
and then the next day comes over and
says oh yeah by the way i'm making a
content house with
banks because faze is leaving and i'm
going to move there now
the day after telling me that he was
going to move in with me i was like
just get the [ __ ] out of my house yeah
that's some deep level [ __ ]
hey baby i know i said we're gonna move
in but i'm actually moving with faze
banks
so i can get my dick sucked in gta
phase thanks hey baby i love you but uh
i got to move in with face bangs
with logan paul moving i got to make
moves baby how did he mess down
i know it was like she gave him a lot of
chances i know
and she's like and she's way above him
this is like a strong
independent woman who's like
independently wealthy
very successful beautiful
and this guy is a goon and he
[ __ ] this up so bad i'm just shocked
yeah i know well i hope faze banks i
hope faze banks is a good companion to
you yeah
i hope he's a good cuddler mike yeah
yeah that guy's such a [ __ ]
there's one other story i have here how
long we've been going i have one more
story we have been going for
two hours two hours oh
almost exactly we're gonna go for a date
today that's pretty fun
match it and it's my cheat meal day
which means daddy gets to do
food
sorry sorry [ __ ] fried chicken
yeah okay i guess i mean it is your
cheat day so you decide
who deserves fractions basically i i
just
realized to get it to do anything i have
to make the plan
tell him where to be when and it's gonna
involve food
and it's gonna be great that helps
it helps there is an insinuation there
i'm not sure i like but it helps for
sure
no it's friday i mean look i've tried
you you like being home what can i say
you don't care
about going out well there's been a
[ __ ] pandemic too
i know hard to do no we just have to go
we used to do stuff all the time before
the panty
but the pen it's okay like you can eat
trying baby yeah
i'm excited i mean i just never thought
oh i have my second vaccination today
too
yeah moderna baby
it's freddy i deserve modern [ __ ] yeah
second shot
dude i'm going to feel like so awesome
once i get the second shot
and in like two weeks i'm gonna be like
moderna baby
94.1 percent yeah
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] wonderful even if you catch
it it protects against
severe illness yeah baby i deserve
moderna
[ __ ] baby
you know um speaking of white claw gabe
since we're winding down to the end i'm
just going to go freestyle here
friday baby yeah friday baby
why is it not showing up my
my tick tock account so here's the one i
just put out by the way you guys might
enjoy it
it's friday baby [ __ ] yeah it's the
weekend baby [ __ ]
yeah you know i put out this tick tock
that you guys all liked but everybody's
clowning on me in the comments saying
that it's like
yeah they're saying it's like uh imac
kid or something
what's that it's what it goes
and i i don't know but people were
clowning on me they say
wait clowning that it's not good he's an
ipad kid at this point
i don't know what that means they say
with warren hate this is giving me shane
dawson tick-tock energy i don't know
what that means either
what did i do everyone's calling me an
ipad kid what is that
i don't know but i don't know
everybody knows what it is but us
ethan i'm worried are you being held
hostage ian you're the keeper of culture
somebody even said foot soldiers think
it's time we pick a new footlord like
i'm sorry
really yeah people are not [ __ ]
clowns this is like the only tick tock
you've ever made that made me laugh out
loud
i was dying it's funny as [ __ ]
i don't know what's up we're too old
that's like tickle for me
all the other [ __ ] sucks yeah no garbage
everything you're putting out guards
yeah i know that's what i picked up from
that too dan's like
all your other [ __ ] makes me [ __ ]
sick
really and you didn't find one funny i'm
just being a little
over the top but this definitely made me
laugh the hardest of any that you've
made
so what's an ipad kid i looked it up and
it
the urban dictionary thing on ipad kid
is just more compute basically it's just
quackity that's
it i'm like what the [ __ ] is quackity i
don't know
the king of all raids across this is
like some roadblock [ __ ] but everybody
knows what an ipad kid
well everybody who's under 16.
yeah we're just boomers i want to know i
want to i don't want to be out of touch
i want to know what's the ipad kid
i mean i think i get it some nerds it's
quackity that's all you need to know
apparently
i don't know what that means my my first
guess was okay like some
someone who's young who has an ipad and
they're just making tick tocks like
really that's what you took from ipad
kid that's what i'm going to say
that's literally what it's in that's
what they said they said ipad kid
but i mean like my little cousins like
they we found out like one of my nephews
has like a bunch of tick tocks of him
doing like really cringy dances
that he was making on his ipad without
telling anyone oh i think i'm starting
to understand so it's like a kid that
their parents don't pay any attention to
them and they just give them an ipad and
raise them
right oh so that's not necessarily
hating on you oh because they're making
the joke like elo left me with the ipad
that's funny that's kind of funny yeah
that is funny you
left me with the ipad again we're being
too defensive but why did they say shane
dawson tick-tock energy that i took
offense to
i don't know hey zach did you guys ever
get resolution about who
suggested filming you moving
yeah he called me to apologize he's like
i'm so sorry
for what happened zach don't push me bro
don't push him
i'm telling you he's like it was all
about i could tell zach was just lying
right now
it's so easy no i'm still standing that
a b did come up with the idea first
i'm still sticking to well i don't give
a [ __ ] what the polls say fake news
hold on it's did we took a poll on
where was it dan oh really can you
someone like love
yeah somebody or we took a poll
we said who do you think is telling the
truth a b or zack
and i believe it was 70 percent a b
wow 30 zack although i have to say 30
towards zach is pretty
a lot considering a b literally showed a
screenshot of zack saying we should film
it
so when i was listening this election
was a fraud
that was very zack
oh you got that zach was right when i
listened
thank you hey look eva thank you very
much she's just trying to stir the [ __ ]
up
that was my feeling because that message
was pretty
that was a slam dunk that time yes but
he's saying that ab
probably mentioned it in a call before
mm-hmm
i know he didn't mention it a call he
did this is some watergate [ __ ]
okay but then why did you bring it up in
that fashion like you guys never talked
about it before
well how so because if if abe brought it
up originally
it's odd that you would bring it up a
second time like you guys never talked
about it you said
we should film it and then a b
responded as if you guys had never
talked about it as well ab
said that could be fun or something like
that well i need i need to entice him to
help me move
i mean like you know i i you know i need
his help so i'm like oh yeah dude loves
filming so i'm like yeah you won't film
it
you want to make it interesting yeah
yeah right so so are you saying that you
just suggested it that's what it is no
no no i'm repeating what you said he's
saying he knew you wanted to do that and
so to sweeten the deal for you
he expressed like we can do this thing
you want
which is filming right all right you for
you forgot aby you forget
but i always know zack i'm trying to
hold back right now
why are you holding back i don't hold
him back there's 33 percent of the
audience thinks that you're
lying thank you my supporters thank you
i appreciate
okay i hope this doesn't i hope this
doesn't make you sound like a douche
so you got okay i'll break it down so
that day after we stopped shooting i'm
thinking
why was zach saying this how could he
betray me i know it's kind of like a
meme that uh i'm a cloud goblin but i'm
like
does that really think that way about me
what have i done so i was pondering this
and i started thinking about it
and i remember that zach and ian sort of
have like a
non-official competition on instagram to
see who has more followers
not real it's not really ian it's more
like zach trying to pass
wait hold on he's pulling ian into this
now hold on
wants to pass ian right for that number
one spot
um on that day of that episode
i passed zach on instagram and i'm not
saying that's why
but i that's the only reason i could
think that zach would go to that length
to make up a lie that i uh
did you ask me on instagram good for you
dude okay hold on hold on let me
i'm sure you'll pass me after this but
this is not helping the clout goblin
narrative by the way
let me let me recap let me recap so a b
has now put forward wait what ian
i'm like is this what you guys talk
about on your monday call no
it's it's very much high how are you you
know
like hi how are you welcome to my
channel 40 000.
okay hold on let me put let me recap
here before we move on
amy has put forth a theory that
zach is harboring malicious intentions
because a b passed him in instagram
followers on that day
um and that's and you're he's in a sense
lashing out at you and it's
in a type of jealous uh a jealous
rage yeah right zach how do you respond
to that my hand to god
i had no idea he passed me my hand his
hands to god a b your response
did help me piece it together then while
you're lying about uh why are you lying
why am i the only liar i'm literally i
can't think of another
what is it then what the [ __ ] are you
talking about you said yesterday the one
with the camera look at the
like it's [ __ ] 2021 everyone has a
goddamn camera i don't
have a camera i don't have a camera i
don't
if you want to buy me a camera okay but
no i don't i have a question
yes um have you felt in other scenarios
that
a b did something with you just to
record it or
the uh no no i've never felt that way
because i was wondering if maybe you
were having some feelings that
kind of caused this friction no no no i
i was just bringing it up i didn't think
it would turn into a big deal
but you know b wanted to throw down so
now we're [ __ ] throwing down right
here
that's all i'm saying and it's kitty he
won't admit the truth
so i think you ex i mean you guys are
following your instagram followers
closely eh
and and ian are you in competition to
see who can have the most is that
something that's going on
i mean i've just been informed
apparently i am but
let me clarify let me clarify you inside
it on that ian and dan don't post like
mean zack
means like i know white yeah oh yeah ian
ian's instagram is popping though like
he doesn't rarely post but
like when he does post though you guys
are very you guys are following each
other's numbers it sounds like
there's a little bit what this is
it doesn't make me look good it does
make me look cloud goblin to bring up
the argument but i'm really
trying to understand then wow what a
great attorney i'm saying
a great attack i brought it up when you
brought it up what a great attorney you
are
okay guys let's take a look at the you
did say like
i don't want to say that he did that but
here is what he did
like kind of that is the shittiest
argument
he keeps going like this is the second
episode we're talking why won't you
admit i'm saying hello i
understand help me understand then well
let me ask you guys this
let me say zach cannot lie you can
immediately see on his face when he's
lying well let me ask you guys this
it seems that you both genuinely believe
you're telling the truth
he doesn't he does i know this
[ __ ] doesn't so you so zach okay
so is that this week it was this last
week i was lying about the foot the foot
thing when he was between me and dan or
whatever it was what foot thing
what are you talking about why are you
going off on tangents wait yeah hold on
no hold on no because a b there was a
conspiracy for
a b to pass me on wiki feet
now do you need any now that is a
capital offense you're lucky i don't
take your head for that girl
that's something did you forget did you
forget the results of that
and it was me that was pushing that yeah
but yeah oh yeah
you told him yeah
yeah okay
i'm just saying every week i'm being
blamed because it is your fault
let me look at you guys instagram
followers here for both situations we
had proof
that it wasn't me that's true we are
forgetting there's a message of zack
saying
we should film it but hold on let's look
at zach's followers because there seems
to be some friction here about who has
the most followers on instagram
zack has 3.39
900. but
trouble in paradise ab
who's just joined he's been here only
what like
how long you been with us ab since
august
since august so not even like not even a
year and
zach you've been with us for how long uh
going on three years
so a b has managed to pass you barely uh
in such a short time span what is going
on here i'm happy for him
i'm genuine this is the first in here
maybe he thinks you're you're
uh pissed about it no i really don't
care correct me if i'm wrong but a b
didn't you you already kind of had a
social media following before you joined
so you're kind of starting well i had i
had two thousand followers
oh okay okay but it's my it's my tick
tock that's why i'm getting
it's because of my tick tocks recently
he's tick stock style
yeah i don't think people okay then you
go over to ian though ian is the god
he is the king of instagram and kills
with 41 000.
he [ __ ] kills it and i'm so happy
that i mean ian's posts are
bangers every time every time
every [ __ ] slacking dan you are
slacking big time
dan what do you have to say for this
poor showing here on instagram 31.9
that's that's quite all right dan not
unbothered by the uh
because dad doesn't post i hardly ever
post i mean look the last post was the
from the anime thing that we did like
three months ago um dan
un bothered kind of over instagram to be
honest i don't open that app yeah
instagram is
a little tired yeah see that's how i'm
feeling about it too kind of yeah i'll
admit i still post on there but i don't
i
it's like look i'm very happy for you
baby
i am and that's my hand to god that was
no
well here's the real question then it
seems everyone's moved on to tick tock
what are what are our tick tock
followers at
oh a b kills me in that abs got a big
following i don't have a tick-tock
account
i don't i don't know what your handle is
start
underscore star killer it was quick
plug that who left zach are you laughing
you just plugged your [ __ ]
he legit just said which i don't know
well i didn't ask i said i don't know it
but he did offer it
yeah but i'll say i offered it really
fast
abe offered it really really fast
s-t-a-r-i-k-l-l-a
don't forget that underscore you can
find me you can also find me at the same
place on instagram facebook
myspace yeah you're you're just popping
on on tick tock
uh abs um have you guys been seeing his
posts of waking up
his wife lena yeah they're hilarious
genuinely so good
i've been it's been cracking me up every
day
i was a little afraid they're too much
like too close to like youtube prankster
but when dan said there he likes him i
was like all right yeah
i'm cool now no i'm very talented a
little ptsd if i'm going to be honest
ptsd of um of youtube pranksters
this is the one that went viral here oh
i can't listen to music
but oh god i thought music is so bad
it's a prank bro so there's just
prankster music playing
sahur is when the sun goes down and you
can eat is that right
it's the last time yeah it's the last
time we could eat before the sun comes
up
okay oh so you guys do it super early
yeah before before sunrise that's such a
pain in the ass you gotta wake up super
early what time is it
oh my god it's like five oh [ __ ] that
do you ever just sleep in and just say
[ __ ] it
no i used to but now i'm i'm trying to
keep up with it
because i usually i'm up anyways yo
that's the worst part you got to wake up
at 5 00 a.m
like i thought not drinking water during
the day but if i had to wake up at 5 00
a.m to eat bro
do you do you [ __ ] in the morning maybe
or like what is that
let me it breaks your face no i'm
kidding i'm kidding wait let me ask you
this abe and you be honest with me
yeah are all of these 100 real yes
okay and the last the last one i even
cut off because you can't even see her
face
in it like it was just it just i didn't
get a good reaction so i just kind of
she's never in on it
no she's never been on it well she'll
see like sometimes like she'll see like
the wood and she'll be like what's that
for him like you'll see
okay well and he's doing it daily so
like she's aware at this point to expect
but was she really woken up like this
like she looks so freaked out
yeah so no lena always like if you even
if i'm just like to touch her or say
like quietly like lena it's time to wake
up she'll freak out even more
she always like sprouts out of bed yeah
well i have to say they are very they're
humorous and they're great
yeah i i could tell that it's not fake
and that is why
i do like them
[Laughter]
um
so there you go the support the stuff
so so do you guys go back to sleep
uh yeah i usually go to sleep for the
first time um
this was my favorite oh my god
wake up and lina lina will sometimes or
sometimes she'll stay up or
like we'll go to the gym because they
open up the gym in our complex so
here play put on the sound
now let me ask you does she want to be
woken up yes
she does okay that's a good
yeah there you go maybe crushing it
zach what's your uh tick tock to bring
balance
i honestly i i don't know he doesn't
even he doesn't even know
wait yeah oh you don't know you don't
care about it he's just trying to play
it cool
it's funny cool oh you're playing i'm
here
yeah let's see what's um let's see what
zack's up to
can you like me these searches don't
ever work
type z vinyl z okay you don't need to
watch me type it's interesting
silence i sent a link thank you
ian okay we got twenty four thousand
that's not gonna
doesn't you know we're getting there hey
this one hey you've got a lot of views
on these lives
wow these got a lot of views people
started like
doing that trend too like oh this one
was so dumb
oh didn't i comment though did i comment
on this one
i think it was the one before that okay
you just it was on it
you commented on instagram i think you
just stand there and then put on
a joker mask this one has 180 000
it's just you play this song just give
us a little taste
yeah so it's just oh oh
zach with the suit no well i look damn
good i'm feeling confident
you do look good well the top comment is
he is so fine
there you go what you doing zach
nothing actually if you want to call me
cloud goblin it would be my duets to
these two videos of zach's yeah so what
abe will do is he'll do at my videos
and then hope he gets more views on the
duet
i do a duet where i don't do anything i
just sit there like jinx
you know the old youtube channel and
then it gets like 100k views
it does shout out to zach yeah you guys
are on a cloud off
a little bit cloud off we can have it
one way cloud off it sounds
like it sounds like he's winning the
cloud off at every turn zach
and i'm actually going to do it first
let me actually zach zach reacted to a
clip from the podcast what's with the
police here you
what are you following my lead are you
is this a solidarity thing what's going
on with the bleach chair
i i mean i'm the oh my god zach that's
me
thanks for pointing to yourself to make
it clear that that that's you in that
closet okay i gotta watch this
are you following my lead are you is
this a solidarity thing what's going on
with the bleached chair
i i mean i'm the golden boy and
i have to out do a b with simpness
and i see that zach is uh yeah you
didn't solidarity yeah zach's in
solidarity
i'm trying to get simple i'm trying to
get sent i can't
people are saying leave zach alone i
support zach in the cloud off
i'm team zach i want everyone
for sure because it's not fair it's not
surprise i mean it's not fair
that a b is is has is edging out
well thank you ethan that's very nice
here
i'm sure will pass me in like a day and
zach has better engagement too
i'm telling you it's literally just from
tick-tock people
well speaking after this episode zach
will be higher than me
so god bless i don't know you can
you speaking of clout we'll check in on
this later you guys uh
now live on serious note i wish you all
a cloudy
cloudy cloud and lots of cloudy
followers i just want abe to admit
that he's the one that brought it up
first and tell me tell
tell me okay hold up i just want you to
[ __ ] admit it
it's not true so tell me what is the
real reason then this is this clout
thing was me grasping at anything i
could
bro bro no huh
dude just just just admit it i'm gonna
need something more than bro
in a court of law you would be you know
your honor look at the
track record no and according to law you
definitely
yeah no ab actually had evidence in a
court of law you can't go abroad
yeah you're going to jail for life with
this record a lot
anyway speaking of clout
i need that cloud so there's this this
this story i thought was super
interesting i need that clout so there's
this japanese girl super cute
young girl who rides her motorcycle all
over the country
here she is and she's got fans that
follow her and stuff
and she's cruising everywhere and it's
like cool young girl likes a
cute girl likes motorcycles lots of
people are interested in this
well there's a twist my friends
came out that this account
is actually run by a 50 year old man
named soya who uses face a face filter
app
to go from this to this
it's amazing it's so amazing
you're not you don't even have to be who
you are anymore and also this girl looks
so real like that looks like a real
person
wow he does have nice hair his hair is
good the hair is that
i felt there her hair is absolutely
can you believe this [ __ ] he goes nobody
cares about a 50 year old man driving
around a motorcycle so it made myself a
cute young girl
and that's so funny and then he got like
two million followers right
yeah you got something he was right so
he went on this japanese show
and uh came out so to speak
is that you could see his real face in
the uh
side view mirror in the reflection do
you have that photo
uh let me see if i can find it i'm
reading an article about it right now
wow
you know how many dudes are jerking off
to that [ __ ] probably talk to me baby
you got the photo let's see oh you found
the the accidental one i'm looking for
right now yeah if it's on the it's in
the right it's in the right mirror i
believe
say what go back it's in one of these
yeah
for real that's what he's saying the
next one oh so he posted his foot his
micro motorcycle there you go and you
could see a dude holding the phone
right here clearly a dude and a face
here here's his face
can you zoom in more um
that's all i got but you see his face
there and you see a little bit of the
face yeah
oh the mirror they get you every time
man you had such a thing oh i'm such an
idiot i wasn't showing on screen i'm
sorry
oh man because i was trying to find it
i'm sorry
we found it i i know okay so here he is
oop
here he is in the mirror of his
motorcycle here's his body here's his
face
do some dudes dick in hand like
wait wait what is that so there you
go so
zach if the clouding doesn't work out
you can pretend to be a cute chick on a
motorcycle although you might have to be
a future having a cube being a cute guy
on a motorcycle
based on those comments true
i can't believe you did a honk tick tock
oh he does this also don't get about
myself no but he's got a bunch of those
people are feeling good too because they
were all about it they people are like
good good real good good viewership
i look good in a suit tig talks
different than the real world
and zach's defense exactly what does
that mean
like it's like cringe levels are we
bringing me down
i'm putting you up [ __ ] what are
you talking about i'm trying to bring
you up
i'm not sure explain yourself i'm saying
that like on tick tock like you
it's okay for like when that dan was
saying oh zach's pointing at himself
like that's that's how tick tocks go
everyone always you know points at the
duet
it's normal behavior
is attrition is what were you looking at
people were saying trisha is going off
on twitter so i was
looking i pull it up and we have nothing
else to talk about seems like something
with gabby
oh god gabby hannah's been trending
for like a week i gotta give it to her
for that one really what for
she's just she's just yeah
that's the nicest way to put it just
being a spaz
what does that mean i mean if i'm being
serious i pro
i think she's probably going through
some
psychiatric thing like
she's not acting normal really i don't
know
she's just like fighting with everyone
and beefing and posting pictures like
i'm sexy and i could [ __ ] your mom and
your dad
but she's not i don't know she seems
kind of like not
like manic a little bit yeah
um i don't know if i'm ready to get into
all this that's not
not without checking out ahead of time
too
but i feel for gabby
i'm sure we'll talk about it on
frenemies oh so
you guys may be wondering we watch jeff
widdick's
second part of his documentary which is
crazy because it
shows that david was the one
not only he was operating the excavator
driving it and caused jeff's accident
and you can even see when jeff has the
accident david is driving the excavator
no license no professionals there he's
got his one hand
on the controls and another camera he's
holding like this
filming it and it's in that moment that
he goes too
fast and slams jeff into the middle side
part of the excavator
and breaks his skull open i missed the
mark with that one
you sure did david people were asking
throughout the show if we were going to
talk about it but i thought you wanted
to
oh yeah well i just wanted to address
that we're going to talk about it
actually interestingly monday we're
going to not only talk about it
but jeff i think is going to call in as
well on monday
so nice so that should be good
i look forward to talking about it i
have a lot of questions yes dan why are
you laughing
well just that went so well last time
that
for him well i'm just surprised that
he's willing to to do it again but i
mean kudos to him
no it's it's not i wonder if he'll uh
intentionally i wonder if he wants
if he'll want to fight me again i feel
like things ended on a good enough yeah
i think so too
it was rough but he like the first part
was rough he went back he
issued a good correction we said nice
things about him on the podcast
and he's telling his story now which
like you know
is good and powerful because he's all
these guys have
been spending the past year pretending
like david didn't almost kill somebody
for a vlog and now jeff is putting it
all out there
and david's been trending because people
see this footage and it's not like um
jeff was trying to make a statement like
my david killed me and this and that
it was just plainly obvious from the
footage yeah it speaks for itself
that david is just incredibly
irresponsible
dangerous really even honestly i mean
how could he have
ended that thing in a safe way he
couldn't
the situation was was going to be uh
end in disaster yeah well you know
what's interesting if you watched his
documentary which i don't know if you
did i haven't yet so corinna
originally steps up to do that stunt and
she
it's immediately out of control and
she's so she
says david put me down and she goes
david you take [ __ ] way too
far let me off of this angry and then
jeff steps up to do it and he
gets you know almost dies frankly he
really almost dies
and then i saw a lot of people say like
and we all thought that david uh
stopped vlogging for covert yeah he
stopped vlogging because he almost
killed somebody
yeah you know and i think that probably
freaked out a lot of people
but what's interesting and we're going
to discuss on monday is that this isn't
the first time or even
the second time that david has inflicted
dangerous injuries on people for his
vlogs i think even third or fourth
yeah when we were talking about it the
other day
yeah because there was the motorcycle
and that almost
that dude almost died and then there was
another that alex guy
got his eye [ __ ] up he [ __ ] up
multiple people's eyes
yeah and then there was a story he had a
childhood story of a friend
where he threw a pine cone at his eye
and he got an infection
and almost died and he lost a leg and
david is always like so
so he almost died it's like even in this
jeff documentary he's like
i almost killed him
[Music]
so
that's a whole story that you guys are
gonna do monday
yeah yeah but i'm looking forward to
talking to jeff about it
and uh trisha i get to
[Music]
say i told you so to everyone because so
many people were saying that she lied
about this story not only that she put
out a video
years ago when she left the vlog squad
saying that david was dangerous and was
going to get someone seriously hurt or
or killed yeah
she was right about every [ __ ] thing
it's crazy
um thank you
no that's about all i've got here today
folks
what are you gonna do if my brother
passes you on wikifeed because people
are saying that he's actually getting
close
he doesn't have the votes like
here is that going to become a family
problem
well there's going to be a foot war
you know that world war f
i mean he doesn't have the votes who are
you kidding
like he's at five point nine nine right
now that's none with this i wanted to
spell
high i mean that's closer than anybody
else okay hold on right behind him
why is it not dude somebody made one for
me
and i don't even know what to do that
was awesome oh really i don't know
here's the official wiki scoreboard i
want to talk about now first of all
6.8 verse 5.9 i mean no he's close but
the
issue with moses is if i'm being honest
you have 79 picks of me
verse 9 of moses and let's be honest
here
oh what are you people doing why are the
foot fairies going so hard for moses
he doesn't even have a feed picks like
what what is this these are not i put up
my feet for you people and this is how
you reward me
why is moses inching in on me i mean
it's outrageous did trisha do this
was moses calling for this who's
responsible for this
i don't know it could be independent
actors
independent actors going i s there is a
mastermind behind this movement
dan it's i mean you were doing
conspiracy on discord i know you [ __ ]
know anything you better tell me
i if i did i would tell you but um no so
then
i'm not part of this conspiracy listen
dan tell him or i'm gonna get blamed for
it
if there is anything no okay we said dan
there's there are uh there's
compartmentalization
in this conspiracy i only know my
component of it
which is which you the great betrayal
that you're already
aware of which is that it would be
hilarious
if somebody on the staff passed you on
wiki feet which i still
stand by it would be funny
it's not funny i don't see what's funny
about that
well anyway moses is coming up second so
i wouldn't you know
i don't know what's going on there but
uh hey he's a good guy
zach coming in hot here oh we got a new
photo of zach
the whole time the whole top rank this
one's pretty wild
yeah it's all of us and then so dan has
been
what wait how did you get up here dad oh
oh dead you're on the top too
but it's just like what's the picture
okay so honestly
i'll never show my feet dance keep
saying i'll never show my feet i'll
never show my feet
well somebody what the [ __ ] are these
dan these look like snuff films what is
this i don't know
is that your foot i can't even tell it's
like four pixels
i want to talk about feet dude this
photo's gonna be the one that brings us
all down i remember people
i reported it seriously well because
it's not even
it's not even necessarily my feed how do
you know it sounds like there's a chance
i mean it could be i mean it's not
anything from my uh social media or
whatever how was it that you
were all on the top like these people
need to step their feet game up like
this guy's number
this is the guy behind us these are all
conspiracies i feel like this whole
website is just conspiracies
i like it this guy's got the best feet
in the game
no look pretty average definitely not
look at the next person this guy joe
joe's trying real hard with the feet
oh yeah let's check out joe's feet
oh is he there's another one
well there was look he's like on a
podcast is this a foot thing is every
people
starting to get in the war joel
listen i don't think it's acceptable
that there's not a unified message on
this footwork
i have my generals all over the [ __ ]
place trying to get ratings for
themselves
if this show is going to succeed we need
to band together for one common
like cause like i can't have dan saying
oh we need to pass ian and all you guys
posting feed pics
and then moses all of a sudden coming
out from the [ __ ] coming out from
flanking me from left field like this is
just this is guys we need to unify this
is outrageous
together we fall oh he died
wait what happened he died so people
came and boast boosted his foot score
cameron yo this guy passed away and
people come boost his foot score is that
really what's going on
oh he's a disney channel actor yeah i
remember him
i mean okay rest in peace but like
that's just weird that people come boost
his foot score
in response to him dying well we don't
know if that's what happened he wasn't
on the scoreboard before
oh i know who's on the scoreboard
shout out to his family yo that's
inappropriate where hey
rest in peace cameron boyce i don't you
know what i mean
rest in peace you live forever on this
foot
scoreboard
shout out to his family zack shout out
to his family
not funny stop inappropriate
but do you guys see what i'm saying like
it's not funny dan the show
only succeeds when we all have a common
purpose
this is chaos this is mutiny this is not
if you're going to be my top general you
have to fall in line sometimes bro
you're trying like come on well maybe if
you
can come on time which is actually a
comment i just saw oh
you want me to come okay maybe your
rating won't go up
all right well hey this got a good point
jesus christ
holding me to the fire here on this feet
to the fire
i don't know i feel like there's just a
little bit too much mutiny around here
sometimes
well so your concern is that one of us
pass you or your concern is somebody
that's
not part of the crew pastor it's all
dangerous do you understand that when
united
you we stand divided we fall is my point
if we're going to rage this foot war
we can't be spreading our light light
allegiances all over the place
there's one foot commander and you guys
being on this course
the scoreboard compromises all of our
hard work i don't really see how
i mean us being there doesn't interfere
with your school no but you can't be
like oh moses is gonna pass you
or a b everybody vote for a b like this
is just this there's
one float commander do you understand if
i
we cannot compromise the security of
this war well for okay so first you're
gonna lose we all lose okay first of all
this is a
this is a fluid situation okay because
when
that happened a b somebody had added a b
there wasn't moses there wasn't zach
there wasn't me there wasn't any of
these
other people that are trying to climb
the leaderboard
and all i said is that it would be funny
if a b passed you
because he was so concerned about it a b
was like
freaking out about like ethan's gonna be
mad at me
if i pass him i'm like well that would
be funny then
if we got him up there to pass you okay
who do you guys think you are well thank
you
it's funny do i need to review that i
have 4
100 points okay what's
funny no i'm the foot god
you don't pass me okay
this is my foot throne you've gone mad
with power
yeah you've gone absolutely mad with
power
and yeah i'm willing to admit it i'm
working from the inside to bring you
down i'm a revolutionary
you will never bring me down
[ __ ] on me it's like that denzel
washington scene from
911 training he ain't got [ __ ] on me
four thousand one hundred five star
ratings you forget yourself
you act like moses gonna pass me he has
one tenth of the
votes you're by
now i ask you all today now to pledge
allegiance to me as your one true leader
of the foot nation army
so it's not a democracy this is how this
is how wars happen do you understand
this is really how wars happened we had
this common
we had this common thing and you guys
got greedy
you all wanted foot clout and then all
of a sudden you're on the board and now
we're all divided
i do you want to have your own foot
nation you weren't just happy being
under
and being under my
unit listen it's like chess we're
protecting the king
you're the one going what amy
i said it's like chess we're trying to
protect the king you're going a little
palpatine though bro
i am the senate yeah you're out of
control start
listen to this a b said oh i'm doing to
protect you now all of a sudden when i'm
like yo i don't like what's happening
here you're talking about oh i'm ready
to go mutiny and make my own nation and
then what do i got to do i got to go war
with you
and i got to go war with you and then
all of a sudden this nation we had
unified strong the top in the world
is now weak with war and attrition and
infighting i think you need to eat
it and then egg and then it comes moses
in comes uh cameron boyce it comes
like tommy it's stomach acid right now
it comes joe stengato and all of a
sudden
the foot nation army which was the most
impenetrable
fortress on the planet has now fallen to
these [ __ ]
chops who never had a chance and the
prime of our power because of people
like this little foot over here
we are still on top this is classic
i'm paranoid leadership this is
this is uh this is stalin in his late
days
stalin or hitler in their in their final
days
people said all the me all around them
in the shadows
you are flooding behind my back and if i
was stalling i would kill you
i'm hating the kills this is equivalent
to julius caesar finding out he's being
betrayed yes
ee e2 brutus e2 dan
dan is the main perpetrator you're no
julius
no julius you are julius you're judas
and i am jesus okay we're we're mixing
up our metaphors here a little bit now
the point is i'm the foot savior and you
all have [ __ ] will bow
to me sia complex i think this is just
ian who do you pledge allegiance to
i don't ian who do you pledge allegiance
still
i'm not please
that's what i'm saying this is not
acceptable
this is a full-on mutiny love who do you
support at your foot
that's your foot soldier or your foot
god you of course
thank you love gets promoted you're all
fired
love is executive producer i've always
supported it
zach is promoted i've never wanted this
mutiny to happen yeah exactly
yeah thank you zach didn't you post the
new picture just
before we can fit secretly first of all
i respect what
that did zach did it for a gag zach did
it for a gag there was never any
meaningful movement for him to pass me
and now i got you all talking about mad
king you're the mad kings
wannabe mad kings zack you're in love
urine
ian you're in the [ __ ] skull what did
they call that when you they put his
prisoners in
yeah you're in the gulag you're in the
[ __ ]
yeah i'm just saying this feels like how
democracy
yo getting that out of here he was he
was uh
whoever said this was a democracy i am
the senate
yeah you're going to the gulag bro get
that out of here
abc you're going to the [ __ ] good
your head is going on a bike
i just i've accepted it doesn't matter
what i say just go ahead take my head
well somehow you're always at the center
of some kind of beauty look at this simp
you just take my head please please for
two weeks
extend your your uh your foot i'm gonna
cut your feet off for me that's what i
don't want to kill you i just want to
cut your feet off
two weeks in a row i was accused i had
evidence and somehow
33 of people still think i'm guilty
[Applause]
[Music]
that is true uh zach is compelling
though because
look zach is standing back
all right cut the shenanigans kill
switch
of course this would turn into a full-on
war i mean this is seriously how
how nations collapse no zach i know you
support me you're a loyal
when the histories are told they will
write to you as my loyal soldier
you don't why is your understanding is
so twisted
do you think it's okay that we can fit
separated men and women
i don't know what i mean and it's so
interesting because men get the full
rating but women don't
yeah your empire is not that progressive
dan just passed a b and wikibeat
breaking alert breaking breaking
there's movement we have movement thank
god
[Music]
see i don't want to be handed i i
self-reported my uh i'm gonna give dan
you know what dan you're gonna get a
taste of your own [ __ ] medicine five
stars
report the post take it you're gonna
regret that mass report
you know what the one person i'd be fine
with passing is dan
because dan's got a bigger bitter jagged
[ __ ] bill to swallow
you want to know what it's like dan
heavy lays the crown
it's your time to be number one with
these [ __ ] [ __ ] pictures
yeah dan your turn is this dan
is this report justified no
[Laughter]
wait does that mean does it let me i
think i already did it because i think
you're lying
over my uh my account here everyone vote
no on that that is a genuine dan photo
from a snuff film
so weird do it live i'm going to take
pictures of your feet dan when you're
not looking
oh people are saying number one i'll
never be caught flat-footed
ah man this is dramatic
guys look at alfredo i want to talk
about
hi look at this guy get it out can we
get alfredo on wikipedia
oh wikipedia
all right guys it's been a fun episode
shout out to taylor lorenz
i feel like i'm saying her last name
wrong but spelled laurence
lawrence no i think that was right
here she's taylor lauren's on twitter
megan she's a good follower i like her
um she's a good you know
dd mega doodoo well it's friday so
let's all go have a great weekend okay
and we'll be back on monday with a
slammer a friend of mine friday baby
jeff and talking about all this david
stuff that's coming out so that should
be interesting
and um i'm getting a call let's see if
i'm getting spotted
[Music]
thanks for watching everybody
[Music]
[Music]
i don't believe he killed everyone
everybody everybody's dead
he killed so many people he killed a few
a phew
love you guys thanks for tuning in have
a good weekend
and we'll see you on monday slash
tuesday tata
bye-bye say good get vaccinated guys
support
you're listening to the hp podcast what
we got on the scene
could it be poplar shoe nights
what you gonna do with me then and the
whole damn crew
goose and gaps with all the guests
you'll see the best podcasts in the
world take it from me jc
over chair x3 baby we podcast now
you're watching x to the three three
three three you're watching h to the
three three
three three you're watching h two three
three three three
you're watching h two three my drinks
are made wild incest honestly